is the weirdest thing this report comes
out from NBC claiming that Paul Pelosi
husband of Nancy Pelosi answered the
door for the cops and then he calmly
walked back to the crazy dude who told
the police everything's fine then the
crazy dude cracks him over that with a
hammer NBC then deletes the video
resulting in everyone being like yo
what's going on with this the story
keeps changing and no one can tell us
what is re what really happened so of
course No One Believes it
we're gonna talk about that and then we
got to talk more about Elon Musk because
apparently that's the only thing that
happened for the past two weeks Elon got
rid of his transparent his transparency
accountability the moderation team
members and the entire curation team
fired half the staff locked them out we
got the emails it's just absolutely nuts
now there's like a there's like a
lawsuit they filed against them all
right this one's getting interesting
elon's tweeting up a storm saying
they're trying to destroy the company
even though nothing's changed they're
still moderating hate speech but tons of
advertisers are pulling up they're
losing four million dollars per day so
that's why I fired people the funny
thing is all these woke activists who
are complaining caused advertisers to
freak out cause Twitter to lose money
and cost them their jobs I'd like to
give a slow clap to you guys because you
did it to yourselves and now they're
complaining like why am I getting fired
because you gutted your own company's
Revenue how about that we're going to
talk about all of that my friends but
first here's what we got to do
if you go over to pop Vortex we released
a song at about 9am this morning you
guys heard us talking about it genocide
losing my mind we around I think it was
a four four twenty or 4 30 uh today
displaced Taylor Swift on the iTunes top
100 taking the number one spot away from
the current number one hit song on the
Billboard Hot 100. so I want to say
thank you to everybody who listened to
the song who bought the song on iTunes
Now as much as we just hit number one
and we've been sitting there for several
hours
Taylor Swift of course is Taylor Swift
she got wind at her back you know we're
we're promoting the song in our in our
video content she's just naturally
massively famous so uh if you haven't
already got the song you can pick it up
on iTunes it's 69 cents you can go to
losing my mind.com watch the video
listen to the song we're getting
tremendous feedback and really if you
haven't seen the music video you got to
watch it because we've got Taylor Lorenz
Chris Cuomo Don Lemon and and more and
Alex Jones in this video legally
distinct from guests or featured players
they're just in the video because
um you know we're uh we're making them
sing for us baby go put it that way but
uh considering y'all helped us in a
matter of eight hours hit number one on
iTunes and helped us displace Taylor
Swift and no beef Taylor Swift I am
saying this because she is the biggest
right now she has the top 13 I think it
is on the top on the Hot 100 she is the
biggest and we actually got our song to
displace her on iTunes so that's a sign
of respect for Taylor and the work she
did and and and the fact that we're
impressed that uh with your up we were
able to get to the top so what we're
gonna be doing is we got everybody who
uh almost everybody who helped put the
song together before we get started we
are going to recrack that Louis XII that
we cracked open it's a very expensive
bottle of cognac we broke it open when
Elon Musk successfully took over Twitter
joining us today to talk about the news
and more of course is Pedro Gonzalez
how's it going man you want to introduce
yourself yeah I'm happy to be back it's
been a while
I'm a writer and editor at Chronicles
magazine and that's about it I'm a
polemicist I make people angry on
Twitter right on and then of course just
uh very quickly joining us to celebrate
with this Louis we got Luke we've got
Ian Serge Kellen Carter Banks who
produced the song He's also in the video
as well my brother who helped make the
video happen and of course my girlfriend
who helps run the company so now we're
going to take this epic bottle of Louis
XII if you're not familiar Google it it
is very nice and this is a celebration
and my thanks to everybody in the room
who is helping make all this possible
and who I'll put this video together
we'll see how the song does uh the first
song we put out only ever wanted was
totally apolitical and it did really
well it's our first song or our second
song really and it ends up hitting
billboard you know in a bunch of
different charts we're actually looking
at the metrics right now and it looks
like the song is going to do better so
if you guys want to just uh start
pouring the Louie who's first who's
gonna who's gonna come up you guys
coming up to grab it come on it was
Chris Chris was first all right let's go
I've never had this before so this is a
kind of bourbon I'm reading about it
here Louis XII Kanye right oh it's a
cognac oh yeah Louis the 13th I'll take
uh I'm gonna take a louder and don't
spill it
I mean we got a wide shot playing right
now yeah trying to get it trying to get
it out right now just got a wide wide
shot a little bit
here we go I just want to give a special
shout out to Taylor Swift who's an
awesome musician Taylor I'm looking
forward to working with you in the
future man let's make another number one
hit together can I also highlight this
for all you guys this is our louder with
Roberto bug club mug
uh Crowder they also wrote about the
song found on their website so shout out
this is our our spoof of ladder with
Crowder bug club Roberto you know we
like our chickens and our roosters
that's a good amount whoa you can smell
it smells like Band-Aids who still need
some such a pleb
you got everybody
oh that's good
so glad I got that reaction right there
yeah
look like you're drinking it in yeah
don't drink it yeah you gotta cheers
look how much was spilled like a vanilla
party Foul it's like a hundred dollars
worth of Louis XII let's find out why
all right everybody
Cheers Cheers nice work man
all right
I'll take the bottle I think I think
Luke is just constantly trying to find
uh excuses for drinking the Louie you
got to celebrate your victories right so
I think there's a number of news stories
today that we should be drinking towards
so keep that on the table there I agree
you should celebrate Victory thank you I
cannot I don't like to celebrate dates
I've kind of gotten away from the whole
hey it's December 25th let's all party
and just because it's a day but when you
earn it that's when it's worth it the
worse it tastes I thought it was
actually really good headphones not any
headphones there should be a volume
there
seriously uh everybody who's listening I
am seriously eternally grateful to all
of you supported uh who support and
continue to support our work it was it
you know when we released only ever
wanted it took 12 hours for us to hit
number two on iTunes and that's the best
we did and then I knew that if we put
out something that was more political
because we had this one in in production
and right before the election we
probably do way better but everyone's
you know a lot more people are it's a
better response people are saying the
songs they like this one better because
it's like you know boppier and poppier
and all that stuff
so I just want to say thank you for
helping make all this possible without
all of you this would be meaningless
without the human experience without
support from our fellow man and
everything uh I'd just be living in the
woods with a pointy stick and a dog or
something so and thank you to Carter and
Ian for working on it Carter especially
for for doing all the heavy lifting and
uh Kent I know uh you know Kent's not
here because he doesn't live out here
but Kent Welling did all the heavy
lifting on the video we filmed for like
an hour then we send the footage over to
Kent who puts this whole thing together
super quick and it is just it was an
absolutely incredible production and a
special shout out to wombo.ai they are
the company that took the pictures of
these media personalities and then made
them sing for us that we could put in
the video so you can check it out at
losing mymind.com we have uh right here
you can see the video if you want to
pull that up real quick yep we're inside
breeding concocting all the lies that we
use to control your minds and then you
can see uh we have a nice little feature
so so anyway uh can you play a little
bit of it for the show just to give them
a little take I'll just play a tiny bit
because the song you guys got to go
listen to it
[Music]
Break Free
[Music]
get away from it
all right we'll wrap that up and we'll
get on with the news and talk about the
craziness but it sounds even better in
the headphones I gotta say sounds really
good really good uh forgive the extended
uh early opening segment talking about
this I just wanted to make sure I said
thank you to you guys and we did the
celebration to thank everybody who put
stuff together so that being said Pedro
we introduced if we only just get to it
Luke's hanging out hey you know I got I
got the message for perfectly for
today's uh show and it says being happy
and healthy is a revolutionary act
celebrate your victories happy Friday
because essentially there is a war on
your immune system and your mental
health make sure you're fighting it as
best as you can by being happy and
healthy and if you like that message you
could get the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do that's why I'm here right on
introducing I have hey guys thanks for
having me Tim thanks for having me be a
part of the song Carter nice work man
and I really want to I really want to
point people at the music tonight
looking forward to talking with you guys
about whatever comes up and we got a big
show because the table is completely
full we got caught her hanging out as
well yeah you know I've been mixing in a
cave for a little bit but I'm also here
for a reason and would love to talk some
politics where can people find you they
can find me on Instagram Carter banks4l
and the rest YouTube twitters at Carter
Banks
and yeah sounds good we got search press
on all the buttons yeah running around
here there's another guy in the corner
with the wide chart you can see that's
Kellen Keller prices we have a full room
and it's all mail it's all dudes real
sausages sausage fest here guys I was
thinking it but you said all right let's
get into this first story and just uh
let's roll with it because you know we
love the story NBC News mysteriously
pulls its exclusive report on how Nancy
Pelosi's husband Paul calmly opened the
door to cops in his underpants and then
walked towards the hammer Intruder who
bludgeoned him I mean that's basically
it they deleted this video but okay we
got it there's so much to break down
first the story was an unknown third
person opens the door they walk in Paul
Pelosi and this guy are fighting over a
hammer and the guy gets it and hits him
and then the cops are like oh and they
said doing then the story changes
there's no third guy the cops came in
and saw them fighting then the story
changes again
now you've got Paul Pelosi opening the
door and calmly walking back to this guy
if he was really facing an intruder or
being threatened he would have walked
out he would have opened the door for
the cops and said please officer that's
the guy and he would have walked with
the cops not away from the cops so the
question is did NBC News delete this
report because this report was fake news
or was there other reporting fake news
and this is the real news I don't know
NBC said for the record specifically by
the way it matters here what they said
in this report that's now deleted and
people can't find other than of course
the saved videos that are being shared
on social media but they said
specifically that Paul Pelosi quote did
not immediately declare an emergency or
tried to leave his home but instead
began walking several feet back into the
foyer towards the assailant there's also
reports from that NBC program that this
was something that was going on for over
30 minutes again they why can't they get
their story straight here why did they
delete this what is really going on here
and the people who are asking questions
were right all along but but this is
this gets even deeper because NBC just
released another article another report
and the headline of it is quote the GOP
has Paul Pelosi's blood on his hands I
mean come on I mean just when you're
trying to manipulate an event for your
own personal political benefit now we
have such outrageous lies and confusion
and and so many different versions of
events here what's going on I disagree I
think this is just as bad as 9 11. this
is racist not alive no no no no even
worse this is worse than January
6.11 and January 6th and Pearl Harbor
look who hasn't been caught wrestling on
the floor with some guy in his underwear
and a hammer when his wife's not home in
his house like if that hasn't happened
to you like you can throw the first
stone okay yeah but now they're saying
the guy wasn't in his underpants right
why yeah
look they said he was in his underpants
they said he was in his underpants and
then they found zip ties and then people
went where did you put the zip ties and
they went uh he had a backpack they're
like so he had a backpack in his
underpants okay okay well he wasn't in
his eyes okay
no I mean release the cameras they have
cameras they won't release them this
this all could end if they release the
footage and the fact that they won't I
think says something what it says I
don't know but I mean you can go back to
the 9-1-1 call and what does Paul Pelosi
say his name is David and he's my friend
he says I don't well he didn't say that
the cop is reporting what he heard right
and so he's the cop is like he says he
doesn't know the male but his name is
David and he's a friend and he's gonna
wait for his wife that's right now that
it makes sense that the story was Paul
dialed 9-1-1 without letting the dude
know and then was talking loudly in code
saying something like I don't know you
and the guy was probably like don't
worry I'm a friend I want to talk to
Nancy I wonder if the real story was
this guy is a leftist he's got BLM in
his window he's got a pride flag he
lives with Berkeley hemp hippies I
wonder if he was like I need to talk to
Nancy like she's gonna help me do you
remember when that guy climbed Trump
Tower and he said I need to talk to
Trump he was a supporter he wasn't a he
wasn't a hater I wonder if that's what
happened and then when when Pelosi calls
the cops he's thinking like everything's
fine and then the dude ends up hitting
him or something maybe
hold on I got another story for you
what if
the police
hit Paul Pelosi
what if what really happened is Paul did
call the cops no no hear me what if Paul
called the cops and the cops Russian
freaking out break the glass kick the
door in and then see Paul in his
underwear hit him knock him down and
then go oh crap that was the homeowner
and hold on that would explain why they
said the Intruder was in his underwear
it was an unknown man who answered the
door and now they're changing their
story he could have been drunk and Rowdy
and out of control and they would they
were like hey bringing the hobo down the
street we got to blame this on somebody
but but who knows what happened here too
hey yeah yeah that's what a possibility
here well so you know what if no and and
maybe they brought him I don't know I
don't get two conspiratorial but what if
Paul does call the cops and when he sees
the cops he runs to the door yelling or
doing something frantic and the cops
just boom right in the face I wouldn't
necessarily blame the cops like it's a
bad thing if the cops just struck a guy
but if you get a call as a home Intruder
and there's a there's a crazy man in my
house and then you walk up and you see a
dude and his underwear where coming
towards you frantic and yelling the cops
are gonna be like back up and they're
gonna hit you they put the guy down they
Paul Pelosi goes down hits his head and
they go oh crap could we get our story
straight could we play the NBC report
because it was very tough I don't know
why do we have it it's all over social
media it's all over Twitter I tweeted it
out yeah
but but they also reported that the
police officers didn't know the severity
of the situation didn't know that it was
uh Paul Pelosi and that's again just
extremely unlike he's arrived here at
the Pelosi home exactly a week ago today
they initially didn't have any idea
exactly what was going on they knew they
had a high priority call on their hand
what was unclear what was happening
inside the property just behind me
this morning Paul Pelosi is home back at
the house that became a crime scene a
week ago today NBC News learning new
details about the moments police arrived
sources familiar with what unfolded in
the Pelosi residence now revealing when
officers responded to the high priority
call they were seemingly unaware they've
been called to the home of the Speaker
of the House how after a knock and
announce the front door was opened by Mr
Pelosi the 82 year old did not
immediately declare an emergency or
tried to leave his home why but instead
began walking several feet back into the
foyer toward the assailant and away from
police it's unclear if the 82 year old
was already injured or what his mental
state was say sources according to court
documents when the officer asked what
was going on defendant smiled and said
everything's good but instantaneously a
struggle ensued as police clearly saw
David depap strike Paul Pelosi in the
head with a hammer after tackling the
suspect officers rushed to Mr Pelosi who
was lying in a pool of blood what we do
know is he brutally attacked Mr Pelosi
and attempted to kill him after spending
several several days in the ICU Pelosi
who is recovering from a fractured skull
in serious injuries to his arm and hand
is now home where Capitol Police remain
on alert investigators have previously
said Pelosi did not know to Pap when the
42 year old broke into his home how did
they know why Pelosi didn't try to flee
or tell responding officers he was in
distress is unclear fear all right let's
pause real quick there is zero
confirmation that broke into the house
right this is between Pelosi and the pap
the perhaps pleaded not guilty there is
a statement he gave and so what I mean
to say is I'll clarify there is
circumstantial evidence he broken to the
house a lot of it I'm saying is we've
not seen hard evidence the story is as
they claim we've not seen videos we've
not seen like third parties we just have
the two people involved saying here's
what happened and then the cops changing
their story 50 times so I think it's
fair to say why did NBC delete this
video maybe the reporter was lying maybe
the reporter was wrong if you come to me
and said hey Tim this reporter lied I
would say is it a day ending and why so
then someone says yo pull that story
this isn't true I'd be like not
surprising now hold on hold on that
being said
deleting the video itself could be them
trying to manipulate and cover up so if
you told me they deleted the video
because it was true I'd say is it a day
ending and why so I'm not going to sit
here and Trust NBC but their their
report was predominantly based on the
police reports and interviews they did
with the police so the burden of proof
is not on on NBC here it's on the police
officers who are trying to tell you
there's no way the two knew each other
how do you know that were they following
and spying on these two people uh for
for their whole lives again that that
doesn't make sense and another aspect
here that doesn't make sense is this
this suspect that broke into the home
was allegedly a mastermind uh Q Maga guy
who's going to Target Pelosi and go
after her saw the cops and then that's
the moment he decided to take a hammer
and strike Paul that does that doesn't
make sense I don't know how this sounds
but I actually don't care a whole lot
about this incident in the details of it
and what I care more about is the fact
that it was propagandized as a kind of
as an example of deliberate methodical
right-wing violence attempt to
assassinate a Democrat by some Q Anon
Trump supporting person when just
everything we know about like the basic
facts of it say that that's that's not
true and at the same time that that's
happening you know Bill Maher does a
whole segment that this is a
continuation of the Cold War right this
is the Cold War in the United States
heating up he does this whole monologue
it's just absurd right yeah and as
that's happening you have a GOP
candidate I think his name is Pat
Harrigan uh whose house was was fired at
uh this happened in the last 24 hours
police kids almost died police confirmed
that someone shot uh into uh the home
where his parents live and I think his
kids were in the house at the time
and that's that's just one example right
like over the summer uh uh lee zeldin
was attacked and I think there's there's
other recent examples of Republican
politicians who are being attacked and
in some it's obviously difficult to find
like are these people actually uh
Democrats or what are they I think and
there's one politician who was attacked
by what the media characterized as a
Libertarian activist but we don't know
that right but the point is is that
there is a disproportionate amount of
violence that I think obviously comes
more from the left but where the
difference is is in the coverage I don't
believe
your average Maga person gets violent
like I say on average there's outliers
of course but you hear these stories
where Bill Maher says the danger of the
right wing yeah and then it turns out to
be these Jesse smallett incidents yes
but the media always reports it as
though the right cause the problem so an
example is I was in Portland proud boys
were marching antifa started a counter
protest
the proud boys were minding their own
business and walking around with
American flags antifa was antagonizing
and screaming racial slurs did the media
come out and say a peaceful march by
conservatives was attacked by anti of
course not they said you know violent
right-wing group shows up and clashes
with antifa whatever but that wasn't the
reality of what happened that's right we
saw that a whole lot the proud boys
would go somewhere or not even the proud
boys like right-wing groups conservative
groups of March with flags and then all
of a sudden anti witch up and get into
fights and the media would say it was
either mutual combat or violent
right-wingers showed up and then you see
what happens in in New York
the mistake made by the conservatives
when antifa came and showed up to a
Gavin McGinnis our proud boys or it was
again a speaking event and started
throwing things at people and basically
surrounding the outer blocks
proud boys run full speed at him get
into a fight start bragging about what
they were doing and how they fought and
it was all live streamed when the police
arrested them
well the good cop love and right Wingers
said sure officer I'll tell you
everything and antifa pulled their masks
up and ran full speed and refused to
give statements the antifa guys no
charges why don't know who they are the
proud boys they're in prison that's how
it works yep back to Blue right we have
this other story though let's let's
always back the blue don't question that
that's right always support the boot
check out this story in in a similar
vein Vandal throws Molotov cocktail
through Oklahoma donut shop window days
before it was set to host a drag queen
event second time shop has been
vandalized in as many weeks I gotta say
I don't know if uh
I find it really hard to believe that a
guy would put on a Maga hat and a black
hoodie and then Fire Bomb a cupcake shop
even if there's a uh you know drag queen
Story Hour happening or whatever or
whatever you know
like would a trump supporter or
right-wing guy be like better put on my
manga hat before I go into fitness
wouldn't you know I would probably wear
like an antifa costume you would and do
it well not me
but if I were in that person's shoes
right yeah right no right it's a repeat
of the Jesse incident right like this is
maggot country yeah it's literally that
except with a hat well you know the
issue is when one side is evil and plays
dirty they're gonna do things like this
now now look uh you know before the show
you mentioned you wouldn't be surprised
if it really was someone on the right
right yeah I mean I yeah I wouldn't it
wouldn't surprise me in this environment
no if they came out right and they
arrested this guy and it turns out his
name was John Smith and there's photos
of all over Trump's rallies I'd be like
well he's clearly crazy because we think
anybody doing this is crazy be it left
or otherwise or whatever but uh I mean
yeah right considering the environment
that we're in you've got you've got
people targeting kids and and now I
don't know if you guys saw the uh the
Stephen Colbert apologized the Tudor
Dixon debating Gretchen Whitmer says a
guy came to me and said these these
explicit books are in these schools the
Democrats won't give me answer so I'm
voting Republican Colbert goes on his
show and says it's made up it's not real
he was forced to apologize on his show
because if he just did a Google search
he would have realized this wasn't made
up and he opened himself up to
defamation by saying tutor Dixon made
this story up that that happened right
so there's there's a lot of parents who
are starting look when you have Democrat
voters in places like Dearborn these are
Muslims coming out and being like my
whole family is winning Republican what
do you think conservatives like staunch
religious right conservatives are
thinking when they're seeing this stuff
happen to the kids it's worse than that
I mean speaking of Muslims there is a
case documented by Abigail schrer in
City Journal a a devout Muslim uh had a
son who's autistic and he had a really
bad episode and I think this was during
covid so he took his son to the hospital
they lived in wash in Washington state
and because of the code policies he
couldn't stay with his son overnight so
he goes home and the next day he gets a
call from the hospital and they tell the
father well your son's problem is not
that he's autistic and had an episode
it's that he's actually a girl wow and
to this father's credit he played it a
lot cooler than I would have been and
basically
he played along and was like yeah just
what do I do next you know like where
what are the next steps to basically
beginning the process of affirming my my
son's real identity
and the hospital releases his kid and he
takes his family and moves them out of
Washington state because he knew that if
he would have bucked too hard uh social
workers would have gotten involved
because the way that that works the way
that the hospital you know was able to
confirm that he was trans was between
doctors coordinating with social workers
and kind of evaluating the kid
and I mean like we already have cases
where families are being broken up by
these people to transition kids and you
have people that work for organizations
like U.S path and wpath these these uh
trans advocacy organizations that are
saying like these are doctors that are
saying we're working with courts to
teach them how to take kids out of
houses so that we can transition them
when their parents are being difficult
well it gets even worse than that
because in places like Canada and some
European countries If the parents don't
play along don't go along with what the
doctors or the psychologists want the
kids to to do and to go along with the
transition they literally get put in
jail they get arrested for misgendering
their own children and not going along
with the transition of their child so
you come for people's kids and then
you're surprised that the temperature in
the room Rises when you say things like
you can't stop us from transitioning
your kids and we'll bring the courts to
bear on you like you're surprised that
some people might lash out yeah now this
guy either is an absolute idiot who is
doing this as he you know is portraying
himself to do this uh or he's someone
who's you know doing something just for
the Optics there because there was a
surveillance camera in HD he did have
that red Maga hat and either he's an
absolute dumbass who's very stupid and
just has very low impulse control and
then did this stupid act as as a real
act or it was a setup in order to get
those Optics going right before the
election but of course work in favor of
the main campaign issue that the
Democrats have and that of course is
January 6th Maga Republicans bad Maga
guy fire buying firebombing this
publicly lit area with a big
surveillance camera with the red hat
that comes not to mention he was wearing
a mask well he and it was a second time
in however many weeks that that place
has been right it could be a
right-winger I don't know you know but I
just love it's like they learn from the
Justice Millet thing yeah they were like
okay we need the people to actually wear
the hoodies and the Maga hats and yeah
this is my country otherwise no one will
believe it I think that's I think that's
a good point is that every incident like
this is framed as part of this bigger
Narrative of like basically I mean it's
so obvious right like the media is
trying to turn the Paul Pelosi thing
this thing into the case for why you
should not vote Republican uh during the
midterm elections because they have no
other case right like they've completely
doubled down on being insane going into
midterms and I think there's a
recognition of that like well the only
thing that convinced people that could
convince people to not vote Republican
or whatever is to is to convince them
that there's this like imminent Mass
violence that's going to happen after
midterms I mean yeah but from Democrats
well I mean you're hearing this right
like uh it's them they're gonna yeah
well they're saying like vote vote for
us or else yes that's basically
literally like six days until democracy
did you see that guy on MSNBC who said
that uh the Republicans are going to
kill your children best loss I think
yeah yeah he said six days until
democracy house he said they will murder
your children I I can't I was watching
and I was just like this guy's lost it
but hey you know like when I when I say
Civil War everybody that's your cue uh
it's because of people like this drink
there you go hey you got it but he's
going really he's going by the way Luke
poured himself a lot hey I got the poor
okay I got I didn't pour myself the
glass someone gave me the score where's
yours Louie Tim I finished it oh you did
yeah I didn't get myself that much it
was just you know this is a burden not a
gift okay by the end of the by the end
of that glass it will feel like a burden
but yeah
maybe uh I wonder if I can try and find
that video while we're talking you guys
keep talking but uh yeah this guy goes
on MSNBC he's raving yeah and and it's
it's normal to them to have him go on
the show and say this stuff look you
know people people have a meme about me
saying Civil War but my Approach is
always like you know we hope it doesn't
happen we're kind of on that path it may
be an informational informational
Warfare maybe fifth generational it may
just be this but who knows it really
could get crazy this guy goes on and
says six days they could kill your
children and who knows if historians
will even be able to write anymore it's
a while none of the ones that are
currently writing should uh for the
that's my my position but I think that
you actually should take these people at
face value when they say things like
that and I think it's a mistake that the
right makes or conservatives make that
they don't take they don't take people
who are insane seriously like people
like this if given power would
absolutely do things to hurt you and
make your life worse yeah I was thinking
about people that are in pain taking
them seriously like people that are
young people that feel like they're in
the wrong body or transitioning their
bodies like it's not not right to laugh
and joke and point because like they're
they're real people and if you do ignore
them the threat will get worse it could
become a real threat like so it's you
got to take this stuff seriously so when
they're saying things like that yeah I
mean like you you obviously it's funny
to hear that but at the same time it's
like no you give these people the power
to hurt you and they will do it
absolutely because they see themselves
as the victims they see themselves
although the establishment is completely
on their side they absolutely view you
as the oppressor and they're going to
act accordingly I thought that it was
very strange that sky was wearing a Maga
hat maga maga well it looks like a mega
hat I don't know what it says oh really
so they don't know it's a red hat with
white letters and it's got some trim
it's the kind of thing where like if
some random guy some random like
Indonesian dude shout out to Indonesia
went and like burned a house to the
ground and then laid down like a piece
of paper on the ground that said Trump
on it next to that burned Rubble some
media would be like Trump's supporters
and you're like the media the media is
reporting it is a mega hat the David is
yes yes so remember when that football
player like ex football player tried
opening like a pizza in a wing place and
then he vandalized them and then wrote
like Maga and like racial slurs and then
they were like it was actually him who
did it okay that or there was a church
that got burned down and then the dude
put like a racial slur on the ground and
it turned out like it was the pastor
that did it and they were just trying to
frame the right yeah this happens all
the time
right Wingers are not getting in their
cars and driving into cities to seek
these people out I mean the the amount
of work involved in that I don't think
the average person has and if you're
going to commit a crime right check out
the place for surveillance cameras and
and then maybe you know knock the
surveillance camera down but don't frame
yourself right in the middle of it when
it makes the perfect shot of of of this
propaganda that we're seeing shared
everywhere right I think there was a
story in the Wall Street Journal that
actually argued that like it in these
days more often than not or at least at
an alarming rate a lot of these let's
call them hate hoaxes are fake and
they're perpetrated by the supposed
victims yeah like this is in the Wall
Street Journal and I think that's uh so
why wouldn't it be the case that people
on the right might be less inclined to
do this stuff and I think it's there's
an understanding that like you will go
to jail like unlike the left that you
know burned down half the country in
2020 and pretty much everyone who's
involved in those riots uh got off with
either a slap on the wrist or no slop at
all like if you if you get caught doing
something like this and you're actually
right-wing like you're going to jail for
a long time there's just there seems to
be a kind of understanding that the
system is against you and it's going to
punish you severely I want to play this
video
clay Travis tweeted MSNBC historian says
if you vote for Republicans your kids
will be murdered and democracy will die
ladies and gentlemen without further Ado
and a historian 50 years from now if
historians are allowed to ride in this
country and if there are still free
publishing houses and a free press which
I'm not certain of but if that is true a
historian will say what was at stake
tonight and this week
was the fact whether we will be a
democracy in the future whether our
children will be arrested and
conceivably killed we're on the edge of
a brutal authoritarian system it might
be a week away like and he's going this
is what happens they watch MSNBC and
this guy says if the Republicans win
they're going to arrest your children
and kill them like they actually think
in their minds the cop is going to be
like
you know Trump's orders walk into your
house take your seven-year-old in cuffs
and then bring him to a firing squad
what are they what are they imagining
happens in this kind of riding the back
of the Trump bad narrative man the whole
Biden Administration and momentum is
based on look how bad Trump was it's so
annoying and now they're now they're
still saying it they've extrapolated it
to Trump's voter base right and how bad
bad bad they are how bad they are it's
just Nazi propaganda man that's what
Hitler did to the Communists with the
reichstag fire it's just this full false
flag nonsense about creating a boogie
man that's what I'm getting out of it
the uh
the the funny thing is if is if you
juxtapose it to what McCarthy has said
or the GOP agenda is after midterm
elections do you know what it is what is
it entitlement reform
yeah so you have this guy screaming that
you know like they're going to genocide
your kids and then McCarthy's like
actually we just want to cut Social
Security
but it's just but on the other how do I
say this um I wish the GOP was half as
radical
um as these people think it is because
the disappointing thing is is that the
GOP is not nearly prepared to actually
use the the Electoral windfall that it's
going to get uh for nothing it did by
the way I think people are voting
Republican understandably because the
Democrats are so insane but the GOP I
don't think is prepared to actually use
the Electoral gain that's going to get
to change the trajectory of the country
in a meaningful way Bill Maher's a great
example of what's wrong with the left
because you can see it when he says
things on his show about the woke left
and and the whiny Millennial and gen Z
babies and all that stuff it's like okay
he's he's clearly heard something yeah
but he's not actually Googled it like
he's seen a video on Twitter yeah and
then said Heaven's me I'm not gonna
research that so then he goes on MSNBC
and he's like these right Wingers are so
violent it's like bro there was an
Insurrection on on May 29th 2020 where
there were thousands of far left
extremists there's photos of DC with
fires raging it's it's an overhead view
of DCC smoke everywhere they tore down
the barricades at the White House they
set fire to Saint John's Church they
firebombed a guard post in on the White
House grounds and they injured 150 cops
529 worse than January 6th yep no that's
exactly right the president was forced
into a bunker but I'm glad that Bill
Maher will just kind of reflexively you
know do that because it reminds people
that like you you can't trust people
like Bill Maher I'm sorry like the their
tendency is always going to be to punch
right at the moment of decision and I
think that's good that people are
reminded of that because there was a
moment where you know there was that
that the segment that Bill Maher did I
think with with uh with Weiss about
covid and like it was Weiss basically
finally saying like well I'm not
comfortable with like masking things
like that right it's like the rest of us
are like already fed up with this and
but because Barry Weiss and Bill Maher
talk about it now it's fine right now we
can we can start saying like the masking
and the vaccines and all the regulations
were dumb and wrong so I think it's good
that Mar will still kind of misstep and
expose himself I want to share this
photo yeah that's right I just go I just
Google dcblm rights yeah there's there's
this uh view I guess it came from a
helicopter and you can see black smoke
Rising there's actually a wider shot it
shows black smoke rising in several
areas this doesn't happen to these
people like to in their minds this never
happened no you ask them out but what
are you talking about I actually saw
leftist journalists have a big Twitter
Thread about how the BLM protests were
peaceful
fiery but mostly peaceful that's what uh
who said that MSNBC CNN CNN these
there's a journalist who said the reason
why we take Maga so seriously blah blah
is because although there were protests
during BLM they were peaceful and we
didn't understand that when we go out
I'm like are you talking about people
died they literally got killed several
dozen yes people were killed billions of
dollars in damage yeah and then and then
you see you see that MSNBC thing where
they had the panel of trump supporters
and the house goes a cop died on January
6th and they're like no he didn't yeah
no he died later from natural
shot yeah that was the only that was the
only person who died as a direct result
of that of that whole thing let him keep
saying it you know why because
if there's anything you can do like you
know Ian you brought this up with your
mom when you said Biden shouldn't be
sniffing kids and she said he's not
doing that and then you showed her and
she went okay he shouldn't be doing that
if you can show someone not as an
adversary like here's a video of them
ransacking uh probably you know burning
St John's Church here's a video of a man
in Dearborn Michigan saying I don't like
sexually explicit books in my kids
libraries yeah then they watch Colbert
and Colbert goes that never happened
that it didn't happen we looked into it
now all of a sudden that that Normie
aunt or Uncle of yours is watching be
like I actually saw that I saw that
video Colbert's lying Yep this is the
part in the movie where people start
pulling other people out of the Matrix
and start waking them up and if it's
because they're emotionally on the same
level it was like with the the whole uh
replacement Theory thing that happened a
while ago I wrote an article on Newsweek
um and it was just so easy to show that
the Democratic party has for decades
made it an official electoral strategy
to Simply replace the electorate like
it's it's they say it openly you know
like that basically fewer white people
means more wins for us like this is this
is not me saying this this is the
Democratic party saying it's and this is
why it fell apart was because it's like
no no we can just quote the New York
Times saying this but when Tucker
Carlson said this is what they're saying
they said he's promoting great
replacement that's right and it's like
he's quoting Democrats yes it's like
right the New York Times is promoting
the great replacement Charles blow you
know like the it's it's Democrat
politicians who are promoting it Tucker
is just repeating what you're saying in
your own words so no you're right like
the do you allow these people to just
show you who they really are yeah but
you're not celebrating and cheering it
on so he's he's man bad but I do think
the the white angle is the incorrect
angle like I really don't care if a
bunch of uh Venezuelans come to the
United States for the most part because
they hate Communists like that's the
reason they're fleeing so typically when
you see like in my in Miami you'll meet
Venezuelans and Cubans they're like
communism is trash we love America this
is a great country Free Speech free
enterprise and I'm like I liked it these
are these are good people so it's not
it's not about race it's about values
the problem we have is they're bringing
in people who are just looking for an
economic opportunity and it's not it's
nothing to do with any of this when you
see people coming across the border it's
like I can make more money here they
don't know our values they don't believe
in our values and that's an issue for us
because Democrats are trying to bring in
people to to allow them to get political
power either through the census or
through creating new demographics new
voter bases but they're creating a
demographic of people who are like just
want something
so then you get voters who are like
don't care don't know if you give me
something I'll vote for you that's why
Joe Biden's like I'll give you 10 grand
towards your student loans I think I
mean there's there's a whole argument to
make that you know that the the identity
aspect does matter but from my position
I just think it's ghoulish to to
basically celebrate uh and Advocate
replacing the core demographic of a
country when has it ever happened before
when is it when has it been openly
discussed in human history like let's
take the the you know like the stock
population and just replace them yeah
it's not like I think the Romans for
sure but they don't talk jointly about
themselves I'm saying like that that's
just this has never happened before it
never in human history has a society uh
talked about its own core demographic
population like that like the Romans
didn't say we're going to replace
ourselves or something like that no no
they would replace the conquered Gauls
with Romans I really don't think that
anything is I don't I don't think the
immutable identity thing matters when
Candace Owens comes out they say she's a
white supremacist I get that too it's
because there's yeah that's the point
like if if what look the white liberals
not in agree with whatever they say so
it works for them
any other group that agrees that they
say it works for them but it's it's not
about race they'll come out and claim
you know this this white person who is
engaging in racist activities isn't
racist if it's in favor of them
affirmative action for instance or
creating segregated libraries like they
they did that educational thing and I
can't remember where it's Seattle or
whatever Dearborn did this with POC and
non-poc digital cafes if it's a white
person doing that it's not racist if
it's a conservative person if it's a
conservative white person no matter what
you do it's racist but if you're a
conservative black person if you're
Larry Elder you're the black face of
white supremacy so what I see is they're
looking for a way to bring in people who
don't care about the American ideology
the American way of life that's all that
matters if you were born in America and
you're a Marxist and you hate America
you are welcome they're not going to
insult you they're not going to smear
you you're you're good you're golden
even if you're white if you're a black
conservative but you believe in American
values and Free Speech you're a white
supremacist
yeah or Uncle Tom yeah I mean yeah sure
I think I think there's a middle ground
there between people like me and people
like you I mean that basically
yeah it does seem to be a a policy of
the Democrats to simply try to replace
the demographics that they view as
Troublesome whether or not that that's
actually true uh well that is that's
what they Advocate yeah it's a it's a
correlation right this country in the
60s I think was like 90 some odd percent
white most of these people are you know
they're Christian they're meritocratic
they're anti-communist sure so the
easiest way to Target that demographic
is the surface level racial attack
exploit racial animosity I mean I think
this is part of like the Communist
strategy for subverting a country
but the reality is you can be of any
background and have values that we think
are good and the Democrats will try to
destroy you they'll lie about you
they'll smear you and they don't want
you here yeah I think the ultimately
what we're talking about is assimilation
and I think that
what we're saying is that people that
come to this country are expected to
assimilate into certain values right in
my position is just that the things that
we refer to as American values uh
originate in a specific demographic and
that's not to say that other people
can't you know assimilate into that but
a simulation is very tricky it requires
pauses in Immigration it requires a kind
of a basic understanding of like house
rules we don't have that you know
anything goes except of course the
things that we can characterize as races
so yeah I mean I think there's a there's
an agreement there let's jump to Twitter
sure we have this beautiful tweet from
our good friend Will Chamberlain how's
it going well shout out he says Elon
Musk has fired the curation team the
human rights team the ethics team
transparency and accountability team
nothing of value was lost Bravo so um
this individual said yesterday was my
last day at Twitter the entire human
rights team has been cut from the
company why is there a human rights team
at Twitter it is a tech platform for you
to send words to the to the to people
why do they have a human rights team
well according to what I'm seeing online
they were specifically going after
people who were calling for bodily
autonomy calling for medical freedom and
for uh parental rights so there you go
they were going after those specific
individuals I love this one though sorry
good the curation team uh the entire
curation team was fired
I'm very happy about this because
Twitter once put on their what's Trend
what's happening Trend trending tab for
like two weeks a fake story about me
totally fabricated completely insane and
people were commenting on Twitter being
like why is this really weird fake story
trending when no one's talking about it
it's not relevant it's not political
it's just a hit piece what was the story
um I'm not going to get into it okay
it's just a fake story fabricated in
every respect okay and Twitter's
curation team decided they should make
sure all of their users see a story that
no one cared about and the response for
most people was like why is this
trending this story is clearly fake
because they're ideological because
these people are are Marxist leftist
cult members and so anything they can do
to attack their ideological enemies they
do so good riddance to them and then we
have Ben Collins he's also one of these
fake news guys he says the entire ethics
transparency and accountability team at
Twitter is gone if you want a sense of
where the site is headed where is it
headed where is a tech platform headed
that doesn't have a ethics team yeah
yeah look man that's what I call bloat
that guy Ben Collins his uh
bio on Twitter is dystopia beat which is
hilarious because he just runs cover for
actual dystopia yeah he just writes fake
stuff right that's right no I think that
um
I I have noticed that I'm being targeted
less with like tweets people and content
that I hate whereas like before I would
log in and be bombarded with like you
know Pro Ukrainian War propaganda people
screaming about how the US needs to get
involved and stuff and I hated it
because I don't follow any of these
people like I don't follow the Kiev post
or the key of independent right but I
would I'd open my app and there would be
somebody saying that the United States
has to continue giving Ukraine Aid like
after midterms I mean why am I seeing
this you know God yeah no it's just I've
just noticed that like in the last few
days I don't see that anymore so Elon
musk's Eight dollar plan
is striking at the hearts of U.S cyber
command operations manipulation Etc
so we learned this 10 years ago or so
from this leak that the US government
was producing sock puppet accounts that
private companies would make a series of
fake Bots or Bots and sock puppets a
sock puppet is an account that looks
like a real person that you control so
you know a soccer sock puppet would be
John Doe has 10 accounts one is John Doe
and then he has Jane Doe rickdo Bobby
Smith and he acts like they're different
people then you tweet something like I'm
a big fan of pineapple on pizza and then
all of a sudden you get slammed by just
10 posts all being like you're you're
disgusting that's really awful oh come
on you don't really like that and it
makes you feel like you're being
unpopular all of a sudden people are
attacking you for doing this thing and
so you're like oh you know I was just
kidding I won't but it's one guy with
Elon Musk doing this Eight dollar thing
the ability of the US government and
other intelligence agencies to
manipulate using Bots and sock puppets
is gone because people are going to be
like I don't want to interact with
random Anonymous accounts sorry I'm
gonna ignore ignore don't care yeah I
mean that was something that I commonly
heard was that people who would tweet
things that you know contrary to the
consensus on the war would just be
swarmed by by just a non-tiny and
non-counts that were either just
recently created or very few followers
that would all be just be basically brow
like I saw it too like my I wrote about
Ukraine and stuff like I would get
swarmed by these accounts like these
nobodies and a lot of them had been
created in the last year or so I don't
really notice that anymore
I just I tweeted this and a bunch of
people got mad I said something like
stop interacting with Anonymous accounts
on and your experience on Twitter could
become way better and this was maybe
like a year ago and then I had a bunch
of people even like real people be like
you're so you're so wrong Tim opposes
anonymity blah blah and I was like when
did I say you shouldn't be allowed to be
anonymous I said if you don't interact
with them your day is better why look
you're allowed to be anonymous I don't
care I think it's good in a lot of ways
but don't expect me to waste time with
1. 1.3 million people you know if if
they're all using cartoon communist
squirrels like dude I am not going to
argue with someone I can't see I'm not
going I hear I hear muttering it through
the wall I'm not gonna start screaming
at the wall I'm gonna ignore it someone
gets on Twitter they don't want to show
their face they don't want to use their
real name you can't expect me to engage
with a million plus people doing that
sorry I see somebody who uses their name
Will Chamberlain right we we brought him
up it's a picture of him and his family
and it's his real name so there's a
strong likelihood I'm actually talking
to someone and that could that could be
fruitful for me I won't be wasting my
time I don't know man you could you
could have a cartoon a communist
squirrel account and it's probably the
same guy arguing with me from 10
different accounts I'm not going to
waste my time with that you're allowed
to be anonymous I got no beef with that
I'm just saying don't expect me to give
you my time if you don't show me your
face I originally taken it to the
extreme and said if you don't make a
video and speak so I can hear your voice
and look in your eyes I'm not going to
respond to you because I don't believe
who that you're who you say you are it's
a little extreme because like I know
Will Chamberlain personally and I know
that's his Twitter account so there are
cases where I'll respond to some texts
and every now I'm a little more relaxed
on it now I want to kind of involve
people but I'm not going to get stressed
out by text go ahead I just want to
point out real quick with the
termination of all of these uh uh teams
this means that right before the
midterms if a hunter Biden laptop story
came out there's no weirdo to censor it
yeah so like the Paul Pelosi thing yeah
it's it's that's it free speech no I
think you're already kind of seeing this
again it might be just be perception
because you know we're excited about the
possibilities of musk making uh
twitterless cancerous but it I mean it
does seem like uh things are getting
through uh but on the point of announce
like I I follow a few anons but the ones
that I follow are like they're high
follower accounts typically uh right
that I've shown that like they're either
like historians or you know like
independent Scholars uh I think I think
good anons can be really constructive
and you can learn a lot from them but
yeah I think there's
a a problem with these these sock
accounts basically right just I follow
swarming well it's not just soccer
counts it's psychological operations
Israel first started to talk about how
they were hiring tens of thousands of
individuals that would just go online
and of course actively work on setting
the perception online as Israel being
more favorable than anyone else the
United States the Pentagon of course
have a similar program but I agree with
you there's a fine balance because we
still should have privacy but at the
same time we've got to be careful when
it comes to the psychological operations
which seems like Elon Musk is disrupting
what will be the price for that
disruption how will the the Deep State
the the Pentagon and all these other
large government institutions that
depend on this for their larger
psychological operations response to
this that's another question that I
think we should worry about oh man I
want you to imagine
what a feature is going to look like
if if Elon Musk has his way if the
Republicans win on Tuesday I'm imagining
mixed race families hanging out in their
front porch the dad's playing catch with
his son he smiles
then the pizza man delivers it off
there's a there's a milk crate from the
Milkman there's two more push-ups it's
gonna be nuts kids healthy everyone's
fit no fat people anywhere oh I'm so
terrified now here's the scariest part
they go to church on Sundays
the bad that my fantasy is is much more
like vengeful
I want to hurt these people because
they've been trying to hurt me and like
not decent Americans that's a bad way to
put it we want to fix the problems you
don't want to become what you're
fighting no I don't mean I mean I think
well do you want to be what they are I
want to I will leave that one go but no
I think I I think the reality is in
order to fix this country like you're
going to do things that are going to
like like the transgenderism right
taking on transgenderism is going to
make heads explode uh and you would have
to necessarily shut down institutions
like you would have to attack uh the
accreditation of Clinics of hospitals
now you're helping people right it is
look yes yes that's right I know what
you mean I don't want to hurt yeah we
don't but I'm willing to change the
banking system and people will lose
their job so you could argue well then
they were hurt but that's exactly that's
what I mean yes you have so many stories
of D transitioners who wish they never
went through with it and their lives are
uh you know irreparably harmed so when
you start coming in and following the
science yeah and actually stopping uh
you know the bad stuff you're actually
helping yes a lot of these people that's
right so you take a look at what's going
on in in Europe and they've already
started doing away with a lot of that
stuff in the U.S they're just the left
is a cult they're they're obstinate
unwilling to look at the data they
believe what the media tells them they
believe what the government tells them
and that leads people to dangerous
dangerous places we need we need to stop
all that and actually just try and be
you know calm about things
and genuinely help everyone so the end
result is I I don't I don't know the
Republicans are going to solve all the
problems I I honestly think they won't I
think there's a handful of good ones
that will will do some good things
they're saying that uh uh Rand Paul will
be the head of like the health committee
or something like that awesome yeah I
don't know I saw that on Twitter and I'm
like oh fauci must be sweating bullets
hey that sounds really good if they win
so let's let's get that to happen at the
very least but the end result of this is
we're not seeking to hurt anybody
nobody's getting hurt we're getting
Justice and accountability when you
arrest a guy who robbed a liquor store
you're not hurting him he may be hurt in
the arrest I get that but we're
ultimately doing it because we want to
help everyone and stop this guy from
from doing wrong ideally in my in my
view we would arrest someone because we
are trying to help them we're trying to
rehabilitate unfortunately I think we
need prison reform and Criminal Justice
Reform because too often we don't do
that
but the end result should be we are
we we are better than they are we don't
we don't go out and burn down buildings
in Riot like antifa does we don't
justify the violence and then lie about
it everything that's happened from this
eclectic bunch of people from
libertarian post-liberal and
conservative has been to make everyone's
life better and the problem is the left
exploits The Good Will and good faith of
those trying to actually help people
yeah I just think that in order to
really like I said do the things that
need to be done like we have to be
willing to to become a little bit more
ruthless with power I mean by holding
people accountable for things like
transgenderism for covid I mean like
you're talking about like I've I don't
I'm not just kidding when I say we we
should have military tribunals for the
people that thought it would be a good
idea to lock people in their homes and
force yeah you don't do a Military
Tribunal for Citizens you do a normal
prosecution like you you don't bring in
the Army to arrest people for a civil
right well you you understand what I'm
saying like I think the the yeah you
just arrest them you arrest them we
charge them and we we first we we get
Rand Paul on the health committee
however it's called then he launches
investigations file subpoenas then
Congress can you know start making
criminal referrals then uh after the
Republicans get in in 2024 we can weed
out the corruption in the doj it's gonna
take a long time but the solution is
a fairly more normal
Congressional inquiries Federal
investigations special counsels arrests
and I I think that's the path to go for
uh go for let's jump to this uh next
Twitter story
Elon Musk he says Twitter has had a
massive drop in Revenue due to activist
groups pressuring advertisers even
though nothing has changed with content
moderation and we did everything we
could to appease the activists extremely
messed up they're trying to destroy free
speech in America now this is funny
Elon Musk himself was fact-checked
it says multiple advertisers have
confirmed they are pausing spending
while they see what direction Elon Musk
takes the platform the growing Exodus of
advertisers comes amid concerns musk
will scale back misinformation and
security protections on the platform
which he did Hank Green famous YouTuber
says you tweeted a conspiracy theory
from a website less credible than the
National Enquirer like four days ago we
all need to look inward as well as
outward Elon responds and therefore
Twitter should die and Hank says of
course not it's just it's too simple to
attribute this to I love how he put it's
just dot dot dot as if he's talking like
why would you do that it's too simple to
attribute this to activists when
advertisers are given reasons to be
cautious you wield a lot of power and it
would be very good for Twitter for you
to do it more thoughtfully Hank these
people publicly came out various media
organizations and told Twitter
they are I'm sorry they told the
advertisers to pull their ads from
Twitter until Elon makes guarantees so
this was like I think it was Media
Matters a few other organizations they
the activists actually publicly went to
the advertisers and got them to pull
their heads so it's just like you know
Elon Musk has Hank try a Google search
seriously what was he talking about oh
Elon Musa do I didn't get the if you
Google search activists are pulling ads
from Twitter you will see numerous high
profile mainstream stories of big
activist groups telling advertisers to
pull their ads off Twitter Elon tweets
that's happening and Hank says you can't
attribute this to activists the
advertisers have real concerns like no
it was literally activists who who wrote
the letters and then sent this yeah even
according to the foundation for freedom
online they came out with a report
detailing how specific individuals
specifically uh Bill Gates were the ones
pouring millions of dollars into dark
money funds to attack Elon Musk to make
sure that advertisers pull ads out of
Twitter and today we're seeing General
Mills Audi Pfizer of all companies
from Twitter yes what are we going to do
I say boycott but there's one I'm gonna
read this Elon Musk says regarding
Twitter's reduction in force
unfortunately there's no choice when the
company is losing over four million
dollars a day everyone exited was
offered three months of severance which
is fifty percent more than legally
required it's true but I just wanna I
just wanna I kind of want to bask in
this if you guys want to just feel the
emotion angry leftists
started screaming at advertisers to get
them to drop Twitter and then Elon had
to fire them because he no longer had
the money to pay their salaries so I
just want to make sure I really
reiterate that they got fired because of
themselves that's just it's wonderful to
see they cost themselves their jobs
that's exactly right they literally cost
themselves their jobs so now they're
going to go home and they're going to
cry and they're going to demand the
government give them money
congratulations
what do you do when people don't learn
right I think the eight dollars a month
tactic is wise because you want to get
away from investors well not you do what
you want to get away from investors you
want to get away from advertisers you
don't want to let Corp other
corporations run your corporation or
decide your things you got to do so I'm
fully on board with this Eight dollar a
month well you never you know quote bite
the hand that feeds you and when it
comes to Big Pharma when it comes to
Pfizer they sponsor a lot of news
reports they sponsor a lot of media
organizations they sponsor a lot of
social media organizations which I think
is fair to say and criticize right now
that that it affects their coverage
their curation of that particular
company that keeps pouring in millions
and millions of dollars into these
platforms that that does result in
favorable coverage for them so going
back to tribunals yes so so overall this
is this is a a great thing that yes
advertisers are showing themselves
they're showing their true colors
they're saying hey we don't stand by
Free Speech we don't stand by something
that we can't control we can't curate
towards our personal benefit you have
increased speech as a threat to us so
we're going to shut this down and we're
going to make sure that we're going to
publicly take ads off of Twitter to try
to bring it all down so I I think it's
clear as day what's happening right now
and I think that eight dollar you know a
month model is something that's going to
fight against a lot of this bull crap
and why I said from the beginning I
would support it I would pay for it
especially if Elon Musk keeps his
promise and only when frees the unbanned
people yes dude my attitude is when he
unbans the political prisoners then I'm
going to sign right up and be like thank
you good sir it's a good product I was
so ready to gamify this website with
avatars that you can buy with tokens and
get them outfits and stuff I was just
looking over my documents uh the systems
that I've built for this Elon let us do
it dude let's go I think uh mostly based
off of how mines does it my proposal was
when you sign up for Twitter every
account is defaulted in the top level
safer work mode meaning any post that's
not safe for work is blurred out unless
you click on it to reveal what that post
is but no Shadow bands if you're
following someone and they're and and
their post is It Breaks the Rules it
gets just blurred and then you have to
choose it'll say this post broke the
safer work rules and maybe not safe for
work you click it Twitter actually has
something like this but you don't need
to suspend or ban people if the rule
break is like hate speech or whatever or
maybe like it's something some kind of
offensive thing
so the way I see it is if you break the
rules you're a single individual post is
blurred if you break the rules three
times your whole account is default into
the second tier not safer work category
people can go into their accounts and
put always show me not say for work
posts and then everyone is identical or
they can stay in the safe work mode and
then every post from you will still
appear in their feed with your name but
they have to click it to see it that way
advertisers don't appear next to it
unless the person chooses to have it
appear next to them that's not the
company's fault more importantly if
someone lands in not safer work mode
from violating the rules you can have it
be that ads don't appear next to these
posts it's that simple and then when you
get put into this filtered mode it lasts
depending on the severity of the of the
rule break between one and three months
unless you commit a crime then you are
off the platform depending on the
severity of the crime for as long as the
punishment of that crime is so like
basically if you commit a crime you go
to prison we get rid of your account
once you're out of prison and paid your
debt then you get your account back
it'll be not safe not say for work mode
for three months and then is restored
and then someone said what about people
who are already banned all of their
accounts instantly get reactivated but
are in not safe for work mode for three
months and then instantly restored to a
normal account no Shadow Banning no
algorithmic restrictions the only
changes it's blurred or it's not and
someone can just click it and it on
blurs
good move yeah mines has a lot of that
implemented already with another exact
work stuff yeah but but the problem is
this isn't about that for Twitter the
problem is they want you gone if you say
something like communism is bad they
want you gone who's they like the
establishment left the cult they just
destroyed their own jobs they would
rather see Twitter explode than lose
this political power you saw this kind
of play out over the debate over blue
check marks right uh the the there is
something deeply offensive about the
idea of people being able to buy one as
opposed to them being awarded based on
what is essentially Prestige Maddie
glacias I think is one of the worst
analysts of our time uh did this thread
and he argued the opposite he's like
trust me journalists don't think that
the blue check is prestigious why are
they freaking out over this no no no no
no I can tell you for a fact having
worked advice absolutely it was like
when I when I started advice people
asked me like oh do you want to get
verified they're like let's put in a
call make it happen yeah and that's
literally I think what they did was they
emailed and then I was verified boom
like that yeah it's a social status and
personality absolutely and they Lord it
over you but but it's not even that we
had I think it might have been fresh and
fit I'm not sure if it was them but they
said when you're verified on Instagram
you're you get DMS you DM you DM a woman
on Instagram and you're verified it's
like you get a date the verification
everyone knows what it means these
journalists only like a year ago
actually one guy recently tweeted I'm
verified on Twitter with 30 000
followers don't f with me and he was
like talking about it's a product like
some company did him wrong and so then
his response was I am verified with
followers and I will they absolutely
view it as a status 100 100
as a social media developer it is so
funny to watch people obsess over their
social media stuff because it is uh
you're a button click away from being
zeroed out just so you know when you use
social media Stephen King what did he
say that they should be paying us he's
right though they should be and elon's
agreed to do it so Twitter is one of the
only platforms it doesn't pay its top
creators so that's a good point yeah I I
they started showing you view count on
your tweets on mobile or whatever and
it's like my tweets get hundreds of
thousands of views or whatever so
Twitter is relying on me to generate
interest in being on the platform and
then I get nothing for it that's why
they did the verification thing because
it was a way to not pay people but trick
them to be active on the platform yeah
right I mean it worked I mean and you
see how taking it away from them is
making them so angry I I agree with it I
love the idea I I it's gonna be awesome
so one of the challenges with
verification the reason why they made it
exclusive was because they couldn't
afford to to look at everyone's ID
there's just too many people
charging eight bucks Elon can hire
people to actually do the verification
process and then what you do when you
get verified is like you show an ID in a
credit card or something something like
I think it's like an ID for me because
Vice did it Vice just said you're good
and they said yes but there are other
people who like you'll wake up one day
and it'll be like hey we're verifying
you because hey it's happening and oh
and then they ask you to send your ID or
something to prove it I say anyone can
do it
if you have a business you just submit
plain as day and then we know your
business is the official account because
someone at Twitter confirmed your
account that's all it means it's just
verifying the official account so that
if you see another Tim pool they know
that you're the one that has the check
mark that's the point and then you don't
need to appease advertisers you have
advertisers sure great but you don't
need them you're not dependent on them
you know Pfizer in uh 2021 they spent
two billion dollars on advertisement
that's a lot of money not on Twitter
just just in general I gotta say too uh
to be honest I did an ad for will of the
people and it had really great impact I
was impressed on Twitter yeah yeah yeah
it it traveled off of Twitter got
millions of hits for not that much money
and then I ended up seeing results on
other platforms from people who had
heard the song and I was like wow it's
actually I'm kind of surprised because I
thought Twitter would be bad let's do it
again I'm sure Elon would appreciate
that we're watching now imagine what two
billion dollars does oh for sure I mean
I think I think we did like five I think
it was like five grand in ads and got
like millions of vets I was I was
shocked by that that's crazy and uh we
we are doing with the new song with
genocide we are doing we have a company
handling it so I don't know exactly
what's going on but they they sent me
like here's the things we're going to be
running and I'm like yeah yeah do
whatever but I'm looking forward to it
um with Elon Musk coming out and doing
this stuff it's a good sign I'm totally
down for advertising on Twitter I will
sign up for Twitter blue the moment he
actually unbans the political prisoners
because otherwise it's just like you
know dude don't don't it's Jack Dorsey
all over again he told me to my face
we're going to create a path to
Redemption and then he never did that
they never had any interest in doing it
and it's it's insane because
why not just let Milo come back on the
platform like no seriously why not be
like hey you were banned for six months
we're sending this email to let you know
we're gonna restore your account and
we're asking you to follow these rules
if you don't follow the rules we will
just have to ban you again we're hoping
that you agree and then they'd get a
power user back but they're it's
ideologically driven they just want the
political victim but Jack was you know a
symbol and and Jack also didn't get rid
of the human rights team
so so you know props to him because
again everyone's freaking out the human
rights they don't understand what the
team actually did the larger effects of
it and it was a net negative to everyone
let's let's exemplify exactly what
happened
to help you understand why what Elon
Musk is doing is so important I have a
tweet here from uh what is this Luke
radkowski I heard about that guy Luke we
are changed he tweeted what kind of
dystopian nonsense is this bullish the
Twitter fact check of the White House
got fact check on Facebook as missing
context this is what Elon Musk is fixing
the White House put out a tweet that
said seniors are getting the biggest
increase in their Social Security checks
in 10 years through President Biden's
leadership there was a flag a tag posted
on that on that tweet that said
actually this is because of Richard
Nixon and the increases due to inflation
it's automatic so the White House
deleted the Tweet Luke shared this image
and Facebook uh I should say AFP label
that is misleading posts claiming
Twitter started fact checking Biden when
you have partisan actors working on your
fact checking
this is what they do but when Twitter
fires them the legitimate fact check
resulted in the White House deleting
their tweet yep and you know I I got a
warning about this on my personal
Facebook page all I tweeted was the
photo of what happened on Twitter saying
now this is a fact check uh just being
like hey this is pretty incredible that
this happened on Twitter and now they're
warning me that my posts could be moved
lower in the news feed I mean they're
already pretty low in the news feed uh
they get very little engagement uh that
people are less likely to see them
because I shared a photo of what was
going on here again this is the fact
Checkers at War here and when you're
seeing this in our social media
landscape this actually gives me a lot
of optimism it gives me a lot of hope to
see this larger Battle of ideas finally
playing out in such an absurd way where
Facebook fact Checkers are fact checking
a Twitter fact check they're helping
Biden yeah
if Twitter was to remain the same
without Elon Musk they would not have
gotten fact checked this way they were
would not have deleted the Tweet they
were lying to the American people but on
Facebook you've got this one
organization called lead stories they've
published fake news about me more than
once and had to retract it because they
put these fake there was one
I did a story uh around the 2020
election and it said something like
Republicans sent slate of electors to
cast a vote for Trump they flagged it as
fake news and they said the Republicans
don't have electors they didn't win and
I said the Republicans did send a group
they called the Slate of electors the
first 30 seconds of the video was me
saying these are not the official slate
of electors being sent by Republicans
they didn't even watch the video they
fact checked it and they got my channel
demonetized and damaged by lying they
don't even do this is the this is the
game and you can see it happening right
now on Luke's on Luke's Facebook on
Luke's Twitter it happened so many times
it's infuriating to even keep up with
because there's dozens of events when
either it's CNN issuing a fake copyright
claim against me taking down my live
streaming abilities whether it's Reuters
saying that my photo from Davos and all
the private jets wasn't real even though
it was an actual photo from Davos I
could keep going on and on how reality
is just being manipulated in a way to
attack people who just try to give a
different perspective a different side
of the story if you're
anti-establishment you're going to be
dinged you're going to be punished
you're going to be downranked in the
algorithm and put in the Cyber gulags
for daring to express an opinion that
these people don't like and that's
absurd and this is an abuse of power by
these big Tech social media companies
that are really run by intelligence
agencies these people think that if
Republicans win
the Republicans will arrest their
children and murder them now I'm sure
not all of them think that but enough of
them probably working at Facebook do and
they're saying I have to do this to save
democracy for fact check false even
though I know it's true it's real for
them absolutely yeah I think that's what
makes them so dangerous and and so
willing to to do this kind of thing
maybe maybe Donald Trump will bring back
the institution the mental institutions
and um but not in the you know I don't
want any negative ones I want ones that
actually help people I don't like the
idea that we send medically ill people
and you know addicted people to prison
people who are unwell need help they
need compassion understanding so when
someone comes out and calls themselves
frog self and thinks that Republicans
are taking children and murdering them
it's like
you are suffering from a delusion we're
not mad at you because of this we don't
hate you because of this but you are a
danger to yourself and to others and to
allow you to go on social media and
organize other people who are suffering
is going to it's going to hurt more than
just yourselves so what we're going to
do is it's called a 5150 a temporary
psychological hold so that we can assess
it you know I think There's real
challenges to allowing the government
the power to lock someone up like that
but there's also a balancing act of what
do you do when people are legitimately
mentally ill
and being given positions of power as
opposed to being given help so they can
get their heads straight well I think
we've we've fetishized this was
essentially mental illness in many cases
I mean like transgenderism is obviously
one of these things uh until recently
was understood to at least be indicative
of some kind of uh you know underlying I
think it's in the DSM-5 it's considered
a mental disorder right yeah I think
they distinct that from it's a distinct
from illness yeah I don't know that and
but well the point is is that uh We've
not only normalized it but we glorify it
you know we encourage that kind of
behavior in other words we encourage
mental illness yeah and were these
things actually require compassion
instead of uh instead of glorification
or you know simply just actually abusing
these people somehow no I completely
specifically we have the neurodivergent
trend you're familiar you're not
familiar with like a fancy way of saying
Autistic or something neurodivergent
means it means you're you're you're
you're suffering from a mental disorder
or mental illness so this starts I think
it starts on Tumblr where people head
starts on Tumblr yes somebody would be
diagnosed with like ADHD or Asperger's
they would say I'm neurodivergent like
meaning your brain is different okay
yeah they would say that it's not bad to
be away from like the norm yeah and like
no but here's the problem all of these
things start from a correct place of yo
we don't hate you for being Divergent
like if you're overweight I don't hate
you I want you to get healthy you know
I'd say you know cut out the carbs I did
I lost a lot of weight you know just I
want you to be healthy and happy I I
look I grew up skateboarding if you
really want to feel good go to a skate
park there's a lot of snooty people some
that skate but if you go to a skate park
and you're really bad at skating and
everyone can see that you're really bad
and then you finally land your first
trick the whole park erupts people are
screaming and sharing every time if if
you go to a skate park and there's like
pros the best of the best skateboarding
and all you can do is a humble kickflip
and you're trying for an hour and you
can't get it and then you go up the
pyramid and you do a kickflip and it's
the worst it's the ugliest in the world
but you get it everyone's gonna start
screaming and cheering and high-fiving
you because it's about you it's about
you doing well and doing better that's
how I view things when I see people who
are who are you know doing better
whatever I want to see them do well and
then I want them to mind their own
business so I can mine mine but on
social media the exact opposite happens
of what you just described because when
you're not doing well when you're afraid
someone when you're delusional when
you're paranoid when you have a mental
disorder you're then praised you're then
congratulated you're then even promoted
in the algorithm which has we have to
acknowledge the elephant in the room and
whether it's you know Twitter Instagram
Facebook Google Talk uh especially Tick
Tock uh especially this instant kind of
glorification this this kind of
algorithm that has been running our
lives we have to acknowledge that it has
had an extremely net negative impact on
humanity and its Mental Health to the
point where we are reaching a point that
there's no going back from where people
are losing their minds and still somehow
deciding it to turn it into some kind of
content where they turn the selfie
camera on and still try to glorize it
somehow and that's non-stop what you see
on Instagram non-stop what you see on
Tick Tock and whether it's uh you know
adultery whether it's it's degenerate
Behavior whether it's just Behavior
that's extremely negative for the
individual all of that is glorized on
social media and we should really be
taking a step back from that and saying
hey we should really uh decide what is
going to be happening here with this
impact on society I think anorexia is a
really good example of of something we
all know and understand is is a bad
thing right it's a bad it's a it's a
negative behavior
um
what's really interesting is to see how
anorexia was spread through basically uh
peer peer groups uh in a thing that's
called social contagion that basically
um one girl would become anorexic
and then her friends would become
anorexic and then through social media
and group chats and things like that
other people who are outside of the
immediate friend Network would then also
become anorexic right because the idea
was to to get their bodies to conform
with some standard okay but the
difference is is that we knew that
things like anorexia were spreading
through pure Contagion
uh through social networks
but we always knew that it was a bad
thing
we always knew that anorexia was
anorexia was something to be treated not
something to be glorified and so you can
basically take this idea of social
contagion and apply it to like you know
transgenderism which I keep coming back
to or whatever like there's so many
other
things that fall under neurodivergent I
don't know uh and and as opposed to with
trans with anorexia which we acknowledge
was bad we glorify it now right like
when someone is skinny like that's kind
of synonymous with being a uh having
anorexia uh we don't do that when
someone is overweight or trans or
whatever or has some other weird thing
like ADHD we glorify these things and it
continues to spread through Nemesis and
so these are anorexia is uh is a mental
disorder I I'm assuming it's in the
DSM-5 this is the diagnostic and
statistical Manual of mental disorders
fifth edition and this includes uh
gender dysphoria so the challenge that
we have I think is
you get banned for bringing this stuff
up yes you'll say something like hey
gender dysphoria is listed as a mental
disorder in the DSM-5 there was this big
push from activists to get it delisted
so that it would no longer be considered
considered a disorder
and then what happened was a bunch of
prominent activists said stop if you get
this delisted you can't get
prescriptions for it anymore it needs to
be a medically recognized Disorder so
that people can go to doctors and get
treatment for you so they were like
actually in their activism for like I
guess the
the status of of being considered normal
I suppose they didn't want to be
associated with a disorder they almost
lost their ability to get to get uh
treatment I think I keep coming back to
the radium fad uh a few decades ago
basically 100 years ago yeah more than a
few decades right okay yeah well we
started applying um radium to everything
like obviously watches and imports and
things like that but but people also
started to um it actually wasn't that
it's not as long ago as you think it was
the women yeah would who are doing the
painting on the watches would brush
their gums yes and their and their in
their faces and then what they would do
is they would smile and their teeth
would glow yeah and then their jaws
would fall off a few years later
here's a look up radio and the radio
Endocrinology here's a really good uh a
really good example for our time
uh for a while it was believed that if
you were a woman you could take a radium
suppository
and insert it into your body and it
would it would improve your female
functions oh wow and on the other hand
the radio endocrinologist was a credit
card sized uh uh device that as a man
you would tuck under your scrotum when
you went to sleep at night and the idea
was is that the radium would make you
more viral that if you had you know
problems what with Mr pool down there
that it would help
um
and so when you go to sleep you tuck it
under there right and uh obviously all
this did was sterilize people really
similar to the stuff that we're seeing
now right in the end they're just
sterilized yeah but but the the really
interesting part of this was is that
Physicians believed in it yeah
physicists believed in it uh members of
the U.S government created entire
institutes like the national radium
Institute people used to drink Mercury
right but and here's here's a really
another really interesting aspect of it
in order to sell this stuff like how do
I get you to tuck some radium under your
scrote right well I tell you that if you
want to be a real man that this is what
you have to do and so an entire industry
emerged to shape marketing to shape
basically conceptions of gender and
sexuality that made it desirable to
start taking radium suppositories or use
the radio and chronology because you
want to be a real man don't you with
like a nuclear something you know that
sounds like marketing you know they they
they they they came up with a product
yes they said this is great we're going
to make tons of money off of this humans
human humans aren't well I suppose
depending on how you put it humans are
either stupid or they're not stupid for
the entirety of the planet we're
actually really smart but who knows
what's out there uh yeah dogs lick their
own butts you know hurry up again no
really quick
nuclearized boners is is a great
marketing term yes it was and it was
super effective and a lot of guys went
sterile humans are not much smarter than
they were actually I think I think what
I read was humans are not smarter than
they were 40 000 years ago we just know
more we've accumulated more data created
data repositories so when uh you know a
new human is born all of that knowledge
has been collected and they can read
through it and learn it very very
quickly and then specialize in it that
means several hundred years ago they
would drink Mercury because they wanted
to cure syphilis and they didn't know
what else to do and they thought it
worked and they were dying and then we
discovered penicillin and antibiotics
and then also we started curing these a
lot of these diseases today or so so
going back then with the the radium
scrote tuck thing they are they're just
people who are like I'm gonna make money
sounds good to me they don't have the
data and then we get the data and then
we're like hey maybe you shouldn't do
that because I'm making your balls but
it was the marketing that they were
doing off of people's manhood
no I'm just right right
my point was that they used that man the
manly stuff was marketed for everything
right like eat your steak like a real
man there's that famous ad that went
viral on Twitter of the husband spanking
the wife because she bought Bad Coffee
yeah and it's like a lot of that
marketing existed no matter what the
product was so like brow beating people
based on their sexuality as a marketing
they still do yeah
but look at the Gillette commercial
remember that one yeah don't be a toxic
man yeah well my my point with the
radium thing is is that it was a moment
where it was like well this this is what
the sign says the sign says that this
stuff is going to make you more of a man
right or more of a woman and we just
didn't know
they thought they didn't know that's my
point right the same way that we think
we do know now everything did they have
short-term results is that why they
thought about that it was like years
later the women's teeth would fall out
their jaws would swell and get cancerous
and fall off I I imagine a tiny bit of
radiation is probably good for your body
no yeah it's heat well I mean depend
ionizing radiation is the sun gives us
some you're talking about it a little
bit talking about thermal radiation not
radio like ionizing radiation all right
so like your cell phone is non-ionizing
radiation I believe it uses what like
microwaves to send signals that don't
destroy your DNA ionizing radiation rips
your DNA to shreds causing your body uh
to be unable to replicate proteins and
then you die so this is electrons the
national radium Institute was founded in
1913 uh by a doctor Howard Kelly a
physician at Johns Hopkins and James S
Douglas who used to work uh for the
federal government so ionizing radiation
result of too much radiation if
radiation gets too insane then it starts
to ionize so the radius you're referring
to I think is like electron Decay when
the electrons are firing off because the
element is unstable hey don't don't be
mad at Ian he's on to something he's
trusting the science he's trusting the
medical experts and the government from
from day one and he's doing the right
thing according to you know the federal
government and the CDC and the FDA I
wanna he's a man of Honor everything
here I want to get this one last story
in because we're going into we're not
going to be here for this weekend we got
the midterms coming up
White House violated ethics guideline by
deleting I like how they say it fat
check fact checked tweet saying Biden
had given American seniors the biggest
boost in Social Security the reason I
want to bring this up first and foremost
the White House violated ethics by
deleting public record but someone super
chatted this to us and forgive me for
not remembering your name they
superchetted saying is it even legal for
Biden to delete public records from the
White House Twitter account that's
public record and lo you were correct so
here we go this is how I guess broken
the White House is they try passing off
a lie and when they get caught they
violate ethics to try and get away with
it now it's only made it worse which is
another example of the Biden
Administration they're digging their
hole deeper someone should make a sitcom
about this guy you know a sitcom about
buying I'd watch that
hey wait wait there is at a laugh track
yeah add a laugh track to you have you
ever see
um those viral videos of like friends
with no laugh track yeah it's so weird
and it's really creepy we could tell
totally take a Biden speech and just add
laughs and it would be like a comedy or
you know buying and walking around or
whatever I'm kind of like I I was more
comfortable when they were lying to me
and I didn't know with George Bush Jr
and the Iraq War at least then I was
like oh they lied everyone kind of
agreed hey they shouldn't have done that
we mostly yelled back like don't do that
anymore now it's like
when it's happening in real time and
it's becomes apparent I'm I'm guess I'm
glad it's happening out in the open now
because where you can see it and we can
criticize it I think that's an important
part of this process
like because it was always happening I
guess and I criticized it too is another
question yeah as long as you don't make
unfounded claims
hmm yeah according to who according to
them according to me sir to them man
seeing the the Ivory Tower crumble When
Donald Trump got elected the first time
I likened it to there's an ivory Tower
and there you know the left-wing
populace and the right-wing populists
come up to the doors and they're yawn
rabble rabble rabble and then you know
Pelosi and Schumer and the clintons and
Obama they're looking out the window
with their pinkies at drinking wine
going oh the rebel is trying to get in
the building
Bernie Sanders knocked on the door they
splashed water on his head and said get
out of here and he went oh okay I'm
sorry about that and then he left and
then the other group of rhyming
populists leave come back with a ball
and then they look down going oh crap
and then Donald Trump who's the bull
smashes the door in and starts rampaging
through the Ivory Tower and I find it
hilarious you know there are people who
are like Donald Trump is a fascist
destroying this country and I was like
I'm just imagining all of these uppity
Elites laugh like like terrified that
Donald Trump is doing these things and
it makes me happy yeah that's all I can
say whatever it's not my choice but now
I'm looking at where we are with with
Twitter
since then it's like Sledgehammer has
been taken to the base of the Ivory
Tower and it's on the verge of crumbling
and they're and they're looking out the
window going stop stop if you let them
keep doing this democracy will end and
it's like okay dude you're up there
we're down here sorry I'm not listening
so you know I'm kind of looking forward
to Tuesday the White House they can
violate ethics all day and night and
there it's it's the desperation it's
become an ugly perfume how about that so
should we Sue or is there somebody sue
the White House for uh violating an
Ethics Clause well I don't know how you
handle this I mean I don't know either
maybe we need to make sure that if any
Republicans do win we're screaming in
their faces like figuratively no you
need inquiries we want subpoenas we want
criminal referrals we have to wait until
Facebook fact checks this so we know
exactly what they think about it and
then we can move forward confidently
knowing that we're we're appropriately
informed judiciously the White House
should keep the Tweet up and then the
fact check should be there as public
record and then they should comment on
the fact check they but they can't the
issue was Biden accidentally said and
the high inflation is my fault they said
Social Security is going up because of
Biden's leadership but it was only going
up trade it was triggered by an
automatic it was an automatic trigger
due to high inflation so he basically
said that high inflation you're
suffering from is because of me whoops
you need to delete that so they were
like we got to get rid of that I used
the phrase through Biden's leadership so
you could you could Define that in a
couple of ways one is like through his
hard work this happened as a result of
his hard work or you could say like yeah
through 2022 we did all this it wasn't
like 2022 did it to us we just did it
through the process of his him being
leader so in that sense you could argue
that yes Social Security did go up
through the period of his leadership but
I think that they were insinuating that
he just brought up so much more
attention to this bull crap they just
literally they uh Barbra Streisand did
this to such a high level that we're
still talking about how they inflated
the economy to the point that they're
giving out record Social Security checks
I mean this is beautiful it's it's
awesome and and again this is mainly
because of you know the change at
Twitter I don't think this would happen
if Elon Musk wasn't at Twitter no they
won't stop the community
exactly agreed and then and then someone
would tweet out the White House is lying
about the social security thing and it's
only happening because of inflation and
then it would be locked it would get a
red exclamation point and it would say
election interference fake news
that's what they just did that to Jesse
Kelly I'm pretty sure they locked one of
his tweets he said something like if you
can't count the votes in a day and
they're still cheating or whatever
that's right well dude
people are allowed to have opinions and
if someone's like I don't like it that
we have a month of voting sorry we're
going to lock your account because of
that there's there's that's that's
clearly bunk but I gotta tell you Elon
Musk has gotten rid of the ethics
accountability and transparency
curation and moderation so what I will
say
going into this weekend is going to be
very interesting because uh there's
nobody at Twitter
the offices are all closed and
everyone's locked out until Monday the
only people who are still there are
critical infrastructure
does that include
content moderation there's pros and cons
that means you can be algorithmically
locked out of your account and there's
nobody there to fix it it could also
mean that there's nobody there to lock
you out of your account
right before the midterm elections it's
a free-for-all yeah so we might this is
kind of like um
it's it's like the the the the powers
the meme magic was suppressed and locked
away by dark Forces and then Elon Musk
he comes into this tomb with carrying a
torch and he sees this large green
frog-shaped rock and then he strikes it
with a hammer and then it cracks and
then green me magic bursts we may
actually see a glimpse of the power of
the meme Magic from 2016 with all of
these people being removed from Twitter
it's going to be like it was where
people are posting jokes constantly the
memes go viral everyone's laughing
having a good time and then Maga
Republicans get memed into office no
maybe it's the midterm if Elon Musk
pulls this off 2023 is going to be crazy
2024 is going to get even crazier oh
yeah the memes the great meme War 3 is
upon us I'm just here for the memes I
don't care who wins I don't care who's
in office as long as we just have the
memes I got an idea for uh Sheamus for
Freedom Tunes it's a guy pulling up like
an old computer laptop and like blowing
the dust off of it and wiping it away
and opening it up and there's a big
folder that says memes and then he
double clicks and he's like we're back
you can dust them off bring them out
bring out all the old memes
do you guys ever see the uh
the uh Donald Trump Keck meme magic mini
documentary Yes actually I have yeah
just talking about how like the ancient
god cack was a frog oh yes was World of
Warcraft that's so crazy yeah I vaguely
I think I remember this stuff see we we
see this is the crazy thing there was a
brief moment where we started to
understand the power of memes and I
don't mean literal magic I mean
Community organizing but then this this
video came out talking about how people
meming this stuff was actually having an
impact on politics they destroyed it and
now we're going back to this curated
top-down world that sucks like when
there were three TV channels you can't
stop the meme though that's why I came
in blazing about graphene when I started
on the show and I just I wanted to set a
meme standard I'm the graph I'm the meme
guy I'm the graphing guy now when you
think of graphene you think of me that
was my intention I memeed it into
existence
when people say things like uh you know
Twitter's not real life I think it's a
misunderstanding of the dynamic that the
internet as with relation to politics
and things like that like actually the
things that happen on platforms like
Twitter can ultimately influence they
they do influence elections and
otherwise the left would not be trying
so hard to maintain control over Twitter
if that wasn't the case right and I mean
you're seeing this in the mainstream
people are saying that you know what
potential changes must could bring to
the platform uh are a threaten to the
outcome of Ben Collins actually was the
one that said this that it could
threaten the midterm elections but if
Twitter a change in management has the
power to threaten elections then that
means that Twitter already has the
control over this and somehow uh control
of the discourse in a way that's
consequential
so I think yeah I think the the meme
magic is really just getting at this
relationship between the internet and
reality which I think it it's
established at this point yeah I would
just say it's not even just the left
it's it's really the the Department of
Homeland Security the doj the FBI no I I
agree that are truly calling the shots
here and saying this idea is banned sure
but I think that I mean the left it's a
category that we use to define something
but ultimately like the left is a
counter-establishment you know
countervailing forces collapse because
all of its views align with the views of
the federal government and I mean to
your point about this I think in the in
the last two years or so Twitter removed
accounts for what it said was quote uh
undermining faith in NATO alliance in
NATO yeah it's on Twitter's official
page it says undermining faith in the
NATO well a lot of uh the Atlantic
Council also uh plays a lot of
fact-checking roles and uh curation
roles they censored a lot of people
critical of the US military industrial
complex many times many organizations
many individuals many reporters coming
out and it's the same as we saw on the
corporate media there's no anti-war
voices there and they're building a war
a world where there's going to be no
anti-war voices anywhere right so yes
and I mean and conveniently the like it
just happens to be the case that the
left's views and tendencies align with
the establishment's views so yep but
it's even further with the DHS coming to
them be like we're going to do this now
we're going to go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com but also
head over to
losingmymind.com and check out the new
song genocide that we put together for
you guys uh I really I want again to say
thank you to everybody who had a little
celebration beginning of the show which
you probably saw
because we hit number one on iTunes
displacing Taylor Swift Who currently
has the number one song on the Billboard
Hot 100. I don't think we're gonna hit
number one definitely not but I think we
might actually chart on the Hot 100
we'll see with your support if you guys
buy the song uh wherever you get you can
there's a you can watch the Youtube
video the link in the description below
or go to losing my mind.com or just buy
it on iTunes it would really help and
we're going to be doing a big push all
next week to get this song done I
appreciate the people who referred to it
as a red pill music video because it
mocks the media and has other points in
it so appreciate that let's read some
super chats
Koba Corey says hot take all speeches
Free Speech anyone who starts to police
it starts to determine what's acceptable
in their own morals only police criminal
activity including obvious violent
threats you're here yep grafty says stay
calm and tweet about it that's a line
from the music video it's it's one of
the graphics very very cool
all right we'll grab some more Andrew ho
says how please have Dr Shiva on your
show as he was the one through his
lawsuit found the back door censoring
portal at The Intercept wrote about then
you will learn the whole story uh that
would be great actually I'd be very
interested in that um I think uh
yeah yeah we had a mentioned the other
day the other day people were talking
about his name exactly as well yeah you
know uh genocide is one of two
alternative rock songs in the top 100
only two alternative rocks in the Hot
100 in the iTunes one oh really what's
the other one number 80 something it's
called
uh Bones by Imagine Dragons and that's
kind of old song alternative rock oh wow
so we're like bringing alternative butt
Rock back called it butt rock well that
was them trying to insult only ever
wanted but it's funny because like bro
you insulted it but we got it's like
almost two million views and it and it's
and it hit billboard like number two in
sales now we're we're number one on
iTunes so we'll see what ends up what
happens on Billboard but this one's more
like I don't know what you describe it
as like pop Rocky pop punk yeah circus
Rock I don't know about sir I don't know
about that hold on maybe if we had some
bigger drums in some like accordion or
something yeah yeah oh yeah all right
Kermit Killa says wasn't a huge fan of
the last two songs but enjoyed the
release today the others were just not
my style good job TC IRL crew there are
relatively different kinds of songs you
know and and a lot of the songs we have
we have a bunch of songs that are very
different but uh you know we're just
gonna release what we release we'll see
what comes next
get out of here
all right Annette Miguel Olvera says
genocide is an unironically amazing song
guys sharing with everyone I know
congrats in the number one spot also
Harley
pastornax government ties are supersus
this is what we're talking about before
the show this is the guy that Kanye
alleges uh tweet tweeted out that Harley
was saying I'm gonna put you back on
medicine throw you back in a zombie
basically middle lobotomizer that's nuts
and this guy's connections with you were
saying the Canadian government he has
connections to the uh Canadian uh
military yes yeah interesting it's wild
doctor grofti says genocide losing my
mind was on repeat Tom Tucker Channel
you Ian that was epic so uh in the video
I'm I'm basically doing a spoof where
I'm Tucker Carlson and then I'm like
watching these other people and I'm like
well you know Alex Jones is there it's
really really fun you do a uh what's
that guy Bill O'Reilly pull a bill over
visibility
when Alex comes in and you're like shut
it off turn it off oh right right right
Bill O'Reilly yeah Alex Jones hacks the
feed and I'm yelling I'm like get him
out of here what's going on we'll do it
that was fun to make that was fun to
make
all right Andrew you says in your new
song genocide what is the symbolic
meaning of the quicksand over the eyes
as opposed to the other liquids and eye
coverings it's a reference to you are
slowly sinking in fake news and lies and
eventually it goes over your face and
you can't see anything anymore and
you're living in a world of Darkness
that's how I view the average person
they've lived in a world for seven years
of russiagate they believe this is
reality they are they are well over
their heads in the quicksand of fake
news how do you get someone out of that
it's very difficult
someone who is passively absorbing
information
they're easier to pull out they're kind
of just sitting there stuck a little bit
but someone who sunk all the way down
encourage them to keep calm throw them a
stick and then let them lay there and
but by being part of stay calm if you
struggle you sink faster that's right
all right Christian Gemma gautian says
NPR published audio recording of an
abortion procedure made me sick to
listen to the derangement never ceases
to amaze me thoughts I am really glad
they did because wow
it was like the voiceovers might be the
worst thing about it yeah because
likening it she's basically liking it to
like childbirth essentially when when
you hear stories from the pro-choice
crowd about abortions they make it seem
like it's no big deal you go in and you
don't even realize and you're done this
video made it very obvious that it was a
it was a taxing and disturbing procedure
where you hear like a vacuum turn on and
the woman's groaning the woman is
groaning the whole time in agony and
they're like you can do this come on
come on you can do it and she's like oh
and it's just like it's so if any if it
like you know what they're turning
people pro-life hearing that like okay
no more of this this is scary I mean
it's like seeing uh like genitals that
are constructed out of people's forearms
yeah that's also disgusting show someone
that show someone a picture of that and
you know the thing that comes to mind is
uh death cult
it's a little term familiar with it
Mark sauce says hey Luke can you make a
shirt with a hammer throw a turtle from
Mario with David as the turtle and Paul
as Mario oh my goodness I have some very
spicy shirts but that would be a little
bit too spicy
for everyone but again still at the end
of the day someone got hurt here it's
not good to celebrate that so no Derek
verbruogi says Breitbart falsely accused
a Libertarian journalist of assaulting
Republican candidate Don Bolduc do you
have any comments on the story I did
comment on the story earlier today and
so far I've seen dozens of people send
me a 10 second video of Don bullduck
running out towards an empty lot there's
like a crowd of people to his right and
then two guys run up to his left and he
starts pointing at one of them and then
the cops run in if you think that's
enough video for me to do a report or
make a determination then you are
incorrect because just like with the
Covington kids when everyone started
sharing this minute or two minute long
video of a kid standing in front of a
Native American and everyone's like look
at the horrible thing he did I was like
bro I have no idea what's happening here
now everyone's saying look here's a
video where a guy doesn't do something
and I'm like and I'm sorry dude if the
guy was falsely accused I have no idea I
I wasn't there and I have no evidence
yeah the guy speaking up publicly and is
saying he did not assault him and that
the exact opposite of that happened and
that he's going to be pressing charges
and a slander lawsuit against
um what's his name uh don the Press I
think he's going for the press or
whatever but but Don also specifically
he's saying as well so here's the issue
I I have you I can't look at a 10 second
video and then tell you wow look at that
bad thing that happened I will never do
that so what's the possibilities I don't
know the report that I saw said that he
was someone swung at him as he was going
to the debate as before the debate I see
a video of a guy clearly leaving
something and then I see him point a guy
out is it possible that something
happened prior and he went hey officers
that's the guy I told you about so look
I'm sorry if this dude's being falsely
accused I have no idea I'm not going to
accuse anybody of doing anything that's
all I can really say but I will tell you
what's really annoying is when a bunch
of activists spam me saying it's a fact
but I'm not going to give you any proof
the absence of proof is proof we're
right I can't do anything with that so
you know like guys I get it man I'm I'm
not a fan of people lying and making
fake news but there's nothing I can do
so
all right Andy Deb says congrats topping
Swift I bought my copy on iTunes today
great song even better video thank you
very do appreciate I appreciate it
all right all right let's try and uh I I
do want to talk about things other than
the song people people really like it
Rose says cheers you guys love the song
best part was watching madhouse say
things she would never say on the air
the truth Christ seeing her smile yeah
we we were trying to figure out for the
third verse which is explicitly the
media explicitly admitting that they're
a machine meant to manipulate you lie to
you and control your mind trying to
figure out who should be the one to do
it you know Michael Brzezinski I thought
would be funny because she had that
famous line where she said it but then I
was like I think Taylor Lorenz is the
right person to sing that line because
she's more more contemporary for like
people in our age group you know
especially with the lives of tick tock
stuff
I really like seeing Chris Cuomo smile
even though it was just like you just
you just our age group what do you mean
by that because we don't know how old
Taylor is no no I'm saying for
Millennials we we know who she is it's a
joke about the fact that she may be 60
years old I have no idea well I think I
think she's like in her 40s is that what
she is like she was born Circa some year
but she lied she tweeted out that she
was 40 something and it confused a bunch
of people and now it's like no I think
she's I think she's she's probably in
her early 40s
she might be she she might be 30 I think
she's 36. she blocked me well she blocks
she's born somewhere between 84 and 87.
like like she's a medieval character
right that we have no idea the records
are scarce about Taylor's existence
breaking the flaw says Tim pool I am the
one accused but was elbowed by Don
balduck it's it's okay video go watch it
I have watched it
so the Covington Catholic video
shows a kid standing right up in the
face of a Native American and there's
like a 30 seconds to a minute and then
everyone in the world even conservative
started attacking this kid I was sent
that and said bro I have no idea what
this video is and they're like people
are saying Tim Tim look at what the kid
is doing and I was getting spammed like
crazy and I'm like what is the kid doing
I don't understand what's going on and
it turned out when I finally got a hold
of the actual full stream it was the
Native American who actually assaulted
the kid and so look bro I get it but
someone comes to me and says I was
elbowed I'm like okay dude I I need
evidence and if there's no evidence
there's like a single video that's 10
seconds long doesn't I can't do anything
with that I can highlight the story and
tell people hey there's this dispute
happening check it out that's for sure
but I can't make an assessment on it
with Covington was there an actual
assault was that anything no Covington
yes so it depends uh this was uh in DC I
don't know what DC assault law is it
could be colloquial assault or legal in
Illinois assault if you get up in
someone's face you've assaulted them
battery would be making physical contact
in a way that hurts or humiliates
I don't know if DC has the same assault
laws in New York assault is physical
harm done meaning in New York what I was
told by cops is you can actually strike
a person but if you don't cause any
visible injury or discernible injury
there's no crime which to me is just
nuts because I mean someone could grab
you but in Illinois if you are this is
crazy in Illinois if I'm 20 feet away
from you and I grab a rock and raise my
arm up I've assaulted you I have put you
within reasonable fear of bodily harm or
physical harm I would think in New York
if you grab someone that that might be
um what would that be like if you're
holding someone and you're not letting
them go that's different than pushing
them what would that be called
detainment yeah someone that would be
illegal but it also depends if someone
has a bruise if you have a bruise you
could say this person caused it by
hitting me here and then that other
person is getting arrested some
jurisdictions it's just crazy the
Covington thing was worse in some ways
because we had video from the beginning
and it just like the charge was that the
kid was being disrespectful towards an
old man like that was even like National
Review they ran a story and they said
that the Covington Catholic kids spit on
the cross
by standing there basically and not cow
Towing to this Native American man
pounding a drum uh they took the article
down I think
so you should talk to Nick salmon at
some point I don't know if you guys know
him he'd be cool to talk to
um mayonnaise says major tornado
outbreak in Texas Oklahoma and Arkansas
right now prayers and thoughts to those
affected sadly I know the dams will be
screeching about climate change tomorrow
morning yeah we were we were in The
Green Room and this is the weirdest
thing we were playing music and I was
showing I think I was showing you but
you're the song yeah and then it auto
played a live stream of warning
tornadoes are slamming all these places
and I was like I was like what's going
on like why are we getting an autoplay
that's not music and then we were like
oh is this live like oh man that's crazy
yeah so thoughts and prayers man I hope
everybody's okay yeah
uh Jaeger tree says the Paul Pelosi
story changing this much and fast makes
you talk so much that no one will care
by the time the truth drops all this
info wagging the dog
yep
yep hard to know man
all right crystal Max says I love the
new song I was skeptical I have to admit
long time listener and just knew you as
a passionate Politico wow you've proved
me wrong well uh check out will of the
people you know what's funny uh we put
up with people two years ago almost two
years ago today to this day and it's
like got a long it's a complex political
narrative and storyline that we did only
ever wanted which is kind of like the
minimal thought process of a song like
there's there's nothing really expansive
about it it's just a typical old song
about like regret and that's it not
complicated and then we put out this one
which is a bit more complicated but uh
much much simpler and overtly political
so we'll see which one does the best
didn't you write this one like 20 years
ago or something the the like the melody
and the uh like the rock of it like the
the the the guitar part I think and then
you know Carter added a bunch to it we
changed we we adapted the lyrics uh
simply put
that like there's been an establishment
Elite machine for a long time
and so writing music complaining about
it for a long time is just like because
of things Evergreen right yeah it's like
Evergreen but uh uh certain parts of it
we like when we started working on it we
were like hey let's let's modernize and
so people are like it sounds like green
day it's like yeah I wrote the guitar
like a long time ago yeah people heard
us playing it a few years ago on this
show on a Friday night and so some
people commented that they were excited
we finally got it done but it's crazy
how you know something that was written
so long ago again we did update some of
it uh but how like it fits so well with
the video that we did in terms of
criticizing the media and all that stuff
all right
Tim Paul's interesting name says hey Tim
I love the video for losing my mind
something weird I released a video on
October 13th with the exact same concept
thought it was interesting we were
thinking of the same idea it's on my
channel it must be true by Tim Pauls I
kind of can't believe that's real
because your name sounds too much like
mine so if you made a video that's
similar it's just it's crazy sometimes
right
Denise Ann says we do not live in a
democracy you are correct yes we don't
correct
what do we got
track media only says remember when the
left blames someone for something they
are really telling you what they want to
do
I agree when they uh when Elon started
taking over we saw these leftists say
he's gonna ban us now and it's because
that's what they would do if they were
given the power they'd ban you yeah
Johnny Atkinson says saw Jordan Peterson
live last night best line of the night
was quote manipulation doesn't benefit
you in the long run deception turns
reality into a force to be used against
you Dems will never learn well I mean
you can manipulate something without
deceiving Jordan where you at yeah
that's true Mal information was one of
the things they're talking about real
facts that are presented in a false
context to to trick people yeah so uh oh
man I think power is the deciding factor
I mean
musk had like it had to be someone like
musk who has power but in in his case
it's money they came in and could buy
Twitter you know so I I mean like I
disagree with guys like Peterson that
basically like inevitably this whole
project collapses I actually I think you
need people like musk you need Elites in
other words in power that they can
ultimately change the tide I don't think
that in the market of ideas things can
just naturally win
um I think you need to decide you need a
decisive Factor whether that's someone
like Trump or someone like musk this
interesting Nate Slocum says depap is
being held as illegally staying in the
U.S from Canada will be deported and
will never find the truth
I don't know about that one but I think
they'll uh those Canadians man we gotta
close the border
it's dangerous legumoth again says if we
all get out and vote we can initiate a
process to accomplish in this country
what Elon has accomplished in Twitter
let us all get out and vote red not rest
on our Laurels and overconfidence and
not surrender to the black pill of
possible fraud or suppression completely
agreed y'all must get your friends go
out and vote Tuesday it's coming up
we're going to be having a a long show
probably that day we're gonna have wings
and pizza and drinks and whatever we
have a rotating crew and we're gonna be
talking about all this just having a
good time hanging out but uh this is it
man
all right Chris Wood says
congratulations Tim on this red pill
song that hit number one LOL it would
take a fellow homeschooler to bring this
to the mainstream
well it's all you guys who made it
possible look I I can sing I can write a
song Carter can engineer it Ian can do
backups and then you know be the
reporter in our video and all that stuff
if nobody watches it it's nothing so it
really is you guys sharing it you guys
watching it you guys buying it when you
buy it and push it to the top of the
charts then all of a sudden all these
other people start seeing it they're
like what's this song why is like a pop
Punky kind of song now a number one
there you go and people are going to
hear it and they're going to be like
what's this all about
there was a really great Super Chat that
I really want to find
uh that man it was just too good let me
see if I can uh if I can find it I
remember it was uh
someone complaining in a funny way
I'm gonna here we go got it there there
is Aaron Berry Tim I am appalled by your
new fake news music video when you
showed a news bar saying fiery but
mostly peaceful drone strikes you
clearly showed a manned McDonnell
Douglas F-15 not an unmanned drone
congrats man great video song great uh
great video great song you are correct
we actually talked about this in the
production I said maybe we should have
it say air strike and then we ultimately
in the edit when it got to the near the
final version it still said drone strike
and I was like No No it should say drone
strike because drone strike is a
political concept we're familiar with
and the video is just the video so I I
know we did show an F-15 but the idea
was to make a commentary on drone
strikes not a commentary on the video we
were playing good catch though yeah very
good catch and calling out Amanda
McDonald Douglas F-15
there we go
Group B says Reddit has a premium
service with r slash lounge and nobody
bats an eye Elon rolls out Twitter blue
with check marks and everyone loses
their minds I'm glad the AOC went nuts
over it we need the debate it's better
than her just being silent and trying to
pass some legislation to screw the guy
over someone just did a GoFundMe for AOC
so she could afford
it's going viral on Twitter I tweeted it
a GoFundMe for it
eight dollars
I I look you know Elon he doesn't get it
Communists don't want to pay for things
it's just it's simple math communist I
want free stuff Twitter should be free
Elon says but we have to pay to make it
work and they go no we don't have to pay
for it so okay dude go to Mastodon or
whatever they like to spend your money
but no they're right you know
all right
just because I like it says I'm always
15 to 20 minutes late to the Stream So I
played at 1.5 speed until it catches up
to live tonight I thought everyone was
drunk talking so slow from the Louis XII
there we go I haven't had alcohol in
like
the last time we opened the bottle and
in a very long time yeah I think I had
like a third of an ounce so it's hitting
me right yeah yeah
Luke stopped you had a fuller glass yeah
you did I'm like I'm like you know
nursing it very slowly last time I had
it was when Lauren Southern poured a
little into a paper cup and then put
some honey in it it's illegal in Poland
to waste alcohol Rusty Shackleford says
Luke and Tim what are y'all wearing on
your wrists also release your songs on
vinyl we we will release the songs on
vinyl we're really excited for that and
these they're they're given to NSA
spying devices yeah when you when you
after you complete training at Quantico
everybody gets these special bracelets
they're they're uh Health monitoring
devices and Communications devices but
they can also be activated to uh it
releases a sedative so if you begin
saying the wrong thing you just collapse
there's a special op devices that you
know if we if we mention certain topics
or certain individuals here
wait wait don't say it it'll activate
the device they're actually whoops it's
called whoop it's w-h-o-p it's a it's a
fitness tracker that's it but also an
NSA spying device you were yeah actually
it all depends if you give them all your
information which I didn't it like uh it
tracks your heart rate your heart rate
variability your calories your stress
your strain temperature yeah body it can
tell you a story right it so technocrats
it is it does kind of annoy me sometimes
but it tells you if you're getting sick
before you even realize it and that's
amazing so I I woke up and it's like
warning your body temperature is
elevated and your heart your heart rate
variability is low and your recovery is
low and I felt fine and I was just like
why is my temperature going up so sure
enough I went I slammed vitamin C and
zinc and then by the next day I had I
had like a light cold and then I was
like it probably would have been worse
if I didn't start taking the vitamins
and that's cool I like that it can tell
you if you're starting to swell before
you feel it I don't like that it can set
your Placebo mind and make you think
that you're sick when you're not yeah
well I've been like doing a lot of like
Health stuff so it's a great way to see
if it's working or not working or what
I'm doing is is going to be good for me
or not for me but don't give them your
private information I'm like I think I'm
a ligma Johnson on here uh fake name
fake address fake email have you found
that they're awesome you know
ineffective uh yeah yeah
all right we'll grab one more Juan
Castle says Tim the bigger question here
where was Luke on the new music video at
least have him play the cowbell well you
know uh when we were filming this uh
Luke I was testing my health with the
whoop app and making sure I was
recovering from an extensive hard work
I'm sleeping I think you actually had I
was sleeping you guys are not you're
knocking on my door you're like I'm like
I'm I just can't I had I had bad sleep I
just Hugh Jennings says you should do an
acoustic version of genocide uh maybe we
will maybe we'll do a special session
like acoustic version and then we'll see
my friends if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and help us hit
the top spot on Billboard I mean we hit
iTunes number one in about eight hours
displacing Taylor Swift who's currently
hot number one on the hot 100. if every
single person right now listening went
on iTunes or just went to the link in
the description below or I think using
my mind.com if you bought the song not
just listen to it literally bought it if
the 40 some odd thousand live
concurrence bought it I'm pretty sure
that would put us in the top ten Maybe
not maybe not that's bold but that
combined with all the streams and
everything we'd probably do really
really well that being said if every
single person who ends up watching this
joke it's gonna end up being I think
like three to four hundred thousand
spent the 69 cents to just buy that song
Not only would that be a lot of money
for the company that we'd use to fund
more stuff we would definitely hit
number one so if you like the song and
you want to support us and you want to
support us producing more songs and even
signing on new artists and things like
that definitely go to losing my mind.com
find the song on iTunes the music video
on YouTube there is a link to buy the
song so you can check that out too
I'm feeling pretty good about this one I
think the response has been really great
so we really do appreciate it you can
smash the like button for this uh show
subscribe follow the show at timcast IRL
follow me at timcast Pedro do you want
to shout anything out yeah just follow
me on Twitter uh and everywhere else
basically at the same handle at eme RIT
uh t-i-c-u-s emeriticus and uh check out
my sub stack at contra.substack.com
right on Carter you can follow me at
Carter banks4l on Instagram Carter banks
on Twitter and same on YouTube Pedro
that was great thank you so much for
coming celebrate your victories the
conversation ends here but I have
another conversation starting up on
lucanser.com I have a forum on there I
just did a video there about the real
Skynet a creepy video about what's
happening in China coming here to the
United States look uncensored.com see
you there Skynet is a real company it's
interesting it's real software being
used in China That's AI facial uh
identification that's absolutely
terrifying but but in China they're
going to use Skynet for good and it's
actually based on the real Terminator
Skynet analogy have you ever I got
chills that's wild hey love you guys uh
Pedro good to see you again man and uh
have a good weekend take care of
yourself get some rest get some sleep
get some water hydrate make love
make peace have fun catch you later hey
guys.com here I'm at search.com uh
pretty much everywhere uh I just want to
say go vote please go vote rally your
friends this weekend if you're doing
nothing the weekend talk to your friends
please go vote the Red Wave is not a
given you must go and vote please and I
want to just say one one thing too like
never forget that Donald Trump won in
2016 and then got three Supreme Court
Justices who then did a bunch of things
you liked is it perfect no but yo legit
if Trump can win in 2016 whatever you
think all you got to do is get everybody
go out to vote and then you would be
surprised there's one thing I'm really
looking forward to if the Republicans
win the Senate and it's looking like
they will but they need your vote Rand
Paul will be high ranking or chair like
the health committee this is what I've
heard it's like someone tweeted about it
and I was just like that may be the
greatest thing I've heard yet and the
one reason why it's worth it if nothing
else I I I'm a big fan of of the Paul's
both Ron and Rand and I've already seen
what Rand had to say to fauci imagine if
he's actually in charge margin has some
subpoena power or actually can move the
needle a little bit that's going to be
really really great so uh but we'll be
back Monday to remind all of you to go
vote on Tuesday and I will say one more
time a sincere thank you to everybody
who bought the song it means so much to
me and to everybody who worked on it
seriously it's it's it's incredible and
I thank you all so much thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time cheers